Hello, everybody.
Hello, hello.
Yes, it is Do Kitty hours because I realized after the
Mugenics stream, I was like, oh my God.
It's a stream about cats, about making cats and being a cat
and everything is just cat-related.
But yet, I forgot to bring out Do Kitty.
I was like, oh my god, my last opportunity.
Why did I use Don't Kitty for a game about cats?
Not everybody wins, because now we get 10 hours of Don't
Kitty today.
Like, it was right there.
She was right there.
Um, yeah, I was like, And I was, I was like, and yet I was
not, that's when you know I was really tired.
I've, I've been really, really tired the last couple of
weeks.
I'm like, I got, it was literally right in front of my face.
And yet I still didn't use Do Kitty.
Um, but now everybody wins.
Now we get eight or 10 hours of Do Kitty for God of War.
was told that it could be eight hours it could be 10 hours
for the the last portion of all my friends was like I'm
gonna try and complete God of war today and I was like yeah
let's run that and then he was like you do know there's like
at least 10 hours of gameplay left like okay well I hope
everybody has a has a lot free time on saturday i hope i
hope we're all strapped in cancel all your appointments it's
gonna be a long saturday today uh patria said even the super
chat thank you thank you call it now chat she finishes the
game next week i have nothing to do today's i'm technically
i do my manager was that um i guess we'll do your work stuff
tomorrow I did wake up really late.
I had a really rough sleep today.
Because dad kept waking me up non-stop today.
Because I think we have new neighbors.
Because he heard something outside.
And there was a lot of movement outside.
And a lot of noise outside.
So he kept waking me up non-stop.
He kept waking me up every couple of hours.
or so i don't know i've let track of time i wasn't even
looking at my phone i just know i've been waking up like on
and off i didn't even look at my phone to be like what time
is it like um but he was not happy he's like who's this
outside the door he was not happy at all so i've been waking
up on and off today so i'm not doing too great i was just
like of course i got awarded um mr broken bond thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you i often get distracted
during long stream so you might need some jingle jangle
midway through is this not enough jingle jangle up down up
down jingle jangle jingle jangle uh thank you for the super
chat mr broken pod thank you thank you um but yes other than
that oh and also i'm eating my lunch right now i gotta fuel
up on some energy at the moment before we begin um there's a
new hawaiian place that opened up Very interesting because
it's very rare to see Hawaii other than Pokeballs because I
don't know you guys know this but Pokeballs originated from
Hawaii.
Other than that like that's like the most Hawaiian stuff we
have in Canada because we're so fucking far from Hawaii.
Same with Mexican food.
We do not have a lot of good Mexican food or Hawaiian food
like anything that's way too far away from Canada in in NA
um that's way too far away from.
within the American region.
We do not have a lot of good food of that sorts.
Oh, hey, Heavenly.
And then, so, there's a new Hawaiian place that opened up.
And it's pretty good.
Like, I mean, they have the mochi donuts.
I fucking love mochi donuts, by the way.
But they also have, like, I've never had these before, like,
before they opened up.
But it's like these rice bowls.
They're not Poke bowls, by the way.
Like, I know.
for me that was a crazy concept because i was like oh my god
like they have more than just pokeballs because like we're
so far from hawaii that like i didn't even knew that like
knew about the other types of hawaiian food existed um and
it's like it's basically like um it's like like this like
grilled chicken like like charcoal grilled chicken and it's
so good i it's so fucking good i love it so much um and you
can like taste like the grill of like from the uh from the
chicken itself oh i tried it i tried spam musubi it's really
good um from the same place too uh but i love spam in
general um patria so thank you the super chat thank you
thank you um guys thank you
me outie dokie happy late lunar new year send you this
orange evelyn all my luck thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you i definitely need it give me all your luck
guys i need all that love oh yeah dad update i realize i
haven't given you guys a dad update in a while but also i've
been all over the place in general every day is a little
adventure with dad um but i took him to a dog park uh
recently um and i swear to god oh my god okay um um he uh
you know i was playing fetch with him and um i feel like i
told something similar before but like it always surprises
me every time and he was about to bring the ball over back
to me because i was playing fetch with him at the dog park
and then um a very nice lady walked past him and he
literally turned around and just walked towards the lady a
very a very beautiful woman was walking the other way and he
literally was about to give me he was walking back to give
me the ball and he you turn and went straight to the very
very nice lady like very pretty lady
and i'm like oh my god please it also happens all the time
but he also like but like another funny thing happened but
he hates it when people don't give him attention when they
don't acknowledge him because like um there was a um you
know i think it was like the lady's husband and then he was
like ignoring him but like the pretty lady was like giving
him the attention and then that noticed it too he was like
why are you not paying attention to me like
and he's just like i don't understand like why are you not
acknowledging me like he looked at the guy and the guy was
just ignoring him because he was just i guess he was just
trying to find his dog and he's like, I don't understand.
Look at me.
I'm cute.
Your lady is touching me and you don't care.
And then he got really angry and he was like, oh, oh, look
at the guy.
He's like, oh, like just looking at him.
He was like, why aren't you paying attention to me?
He doesn't like men, but you know what he hates even more?
People who don't acknowledge him.
He hates that even more.
He doesn't like being not being a center of attention.
Because he's like, I don't understand.
Like, you know, if he does try to, like, if the guy does pay
attention.
If any guy does pay attention or, like, try to touch him,
then he'd also be like, but, like, he also really hates it
when they don't pay attention to him.
Or try to touch him.
He got really mad.
following the guy around because he was confused he's like
why aren't you acknowledging me i don't understand am i not
cute enough for you like am i don't understand am i getting
old like he started following the guy around and the guy was
still ignoring him and he got really pissed stop and he was
like this this is doesn't make sense like this this doesn't
make any and he got really fucking mad and he started
barking at it he was like why won't you love me he's like am
i not cute anymore ever since i had my birthday am i losing
my power
anyway i was like i'm so sorry i was like went up to like
i'm so sorry he's just he just doesn't like it when people
don't acknowledge him i'm really sorry
um also did you guys hear about the monkey punch the monkey
um i mean like a lot of people I've talked about it, but
it's like this monkey that has a stuff like who got like
disowned by his mom so the zoo gave him a stuffed um a
stuffed animal it's like it's a monkey in Japan so the whole
premise is that um there's a monkey it's always like the
primates like something always happening about monkeys or
gorillas in Japan I don't know if you guys remembered but
there was a apparently um there was a gorilla that in Japan
that was dubbed like a really hot gorilla a lot of people
were visiting the zoo the zoo in japan just to see how hot
this gorilla is anyway new primate there's apparently a
little baby monkey um that was this owned by his mom and
then the zookeepers uh gave him a little plushy a little
orangutan plushy to like give him like comfort because no
one nobody likes punch the monkey for some reason and like a
lot of monkeys were bullying him and stuff and um and so it
like it went viral because it's like he's just going around
carrying the little plush monkey um for comfort and stuff
because he needed he had no infection from any other monkeys
anyway so um i thought the funniest shit about this not the
fact that the monkey was getting bullied but the japanese
zoo had to put out a statement and being like please stop
calling us if you don't speak japanese because we don't
understand your language
because like apparently people overseas were spam calling
the japanese zoo to talk to like inquire about the monkey
and they had to put out a say and be like we don't
understand you please stop spam calling us like like we
don't speak this for like we don't speak english or we don't
speak this foreign language.
Please stop calling us.
That was so funny.
They're like, we don't know what to do.
Like, Papa, Smurf, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Am I washed over the hill?
No, the men are wrong.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
hilarious because they are getting a lot they're getting a
lot of attention is apparently like a small zoo in japan too
it's not like a really big not one of the bigger zoos in
japan it was like one of those like small local zoos um so
they're like we don't know how to handle this we don't know
what to do anyway let's play god of war strap up guys it's
gonna be a long day grab your snacks
lunch and dinner we're gonna be here for a while all right
let's see all right here we go continue most likely it will
be either it will be a it will be either eight or ten hour
stream or even more yeah make your dinner right now
snack grab a blankie you're gonna go to bed and then wake up
to see me still playing god of war what's this thing some
kind of altar i do not know also ran welcome to tomato farm
welcome welcome yeah that's when you know i was tired the
fact i forgot to do kitty existed from eugenics like i was
like oh my god how could i forget it was right there in
front of me Okay, this is the first time you showed
finishing God award to the class.
I'm gonna strip above kids thinking this super chat
thinking, thank you.
Thank you.
Oh my god, please, please, it's like driving a car.
I'm gonna fuck him.
Okay, I'm going this way.
Time to see how the vineyard have fared in our absence.
I hope Freya's okay.
I'm gonna get a dairy here.
She can care for herself.
her though her brother's forces aren't numbered there is
much i owe her all right let's see i can remember all the
controls again there's the oh okay there all right not there
we go straight on look this is my first game of the day
please i just woke up
i don't need your fucking mouth right now
You're smart ass, Mal.
Alright.
Where are we?
Read!
Reminds me of a Vanaheim song I heard long ago.
I'm literally like slouching back on my chair.
Yeah, where is everyone?
I don't like this, brother.
uh gun thank you the super chat thank you thank you all i
reacted to it on twitch i'm excited apparently the sons of
spartan though was really bad apparently wasn't even written
by any of the original was it not someone said it wasn't
even written by the original writers or some shit and like
one of the original creators were mad was mad about it was
that true i like skimmed through it um i skimmed it was good
Oh, I saw one of the ritual creators was apparently mad
about the Sons of Spartan.
Kratos, Atreus, a welcome reunion.
Unexpected but welcome.
You know us?
Can't be.
Is that who I think?
Oh, you shifty bastard.
That's almost good to see you again.
And for once in the shape of a man or nearly.
So that's how they got your head out of your ass.
Oh, the creator is just salty as fuck.
Oh, okay.
Apparently the creator is always mad.
Bro, why is he always mad?
I mean, that's why he created God of War, I guess.
Hilda Spini.
I mean, that makes sense.
He took his anger out on God of War.
He's just like him.
For real, for real.
So sorry about that.
Freya's poor.
Her advisor.
and friend counselor to the veneer and yes while exiled at
midgard i was trapped in my bore form and then you shot me
that oh he doesn't even like this game no i guess he's like
why is he not killing everything where is the sex buttons
where's my sex quick time events where are my quick time
events just watch where you aim that ball of yours My hide's
not so thick in this form
You joke, but I'll head out whenever you're ready Where are
we going?
I have a favor to ask Hey, how he's less angry Then became a
father How dare you?
How dare you Find happiness?
That's crazy He's like, how could you?
You're supposed to be and angry for the rest of your life
where is freya she came here to help her brother she leads
the search party for freya or they give a super chat thank
you thank you character development in my game about
violence to make matters worse the celestial wolves haven't
been seen in days if i can't have a family kratos can't have
a family he is my self-insert long story you want us to
check on them you'd have my gratitude we're spread thin and
if anyone can help school like i can't relate to him no more
very well freya mentioned you had a way past this yeah i do
but give me a sec i gotta put that stone in and then i
forgot how how do i do i explode it again guys i don't
remember how do i explode it i oh triangle okay there you go
you don't disappoint but of course it's not like i struggled
for like 30 seconds he's just watching like you don't
disappoint i'm like yep that's me for shooting him trust me
lad the old swine still carried a grudge you'd know it what
happened between you two who was this guy i don't remember
promises nothing to concern yourself with i'm not concerned
just curious curiosity's all well and good but so is privacy
okay okay who was the other he's just a guy oh he was the
boy oh what the fuck he was a human how do i do this must be
like something for later i'm pretty sure
oh no i do listen but i just choose not to
i was talking about the creator of the game guys i was
pretty cocky i wanted to know more about the creator i just
heard like he was like i got shot i was like who the fuck
shot you i was like oh my son But I didn't realize what he
was.
Oh, it's him.
Oh, shit.
Don't worry.
I'll do this.
There we go.
I'm trying to remember how to play this game again.
Oh my god, I forgot my son can do shit too.
That's right!
Using every...
All my specials!
And then...
I'll just do this.
What the fuck?
Get outta here.
That's fucking right.
Get outta here!
Oh my god!
Pressing the buttons!
Oh, there's too many buttons though.
Oh my god, there's too many of these guys.
Oh shit, that's it.
I still have my rage!
I'm still angry!
There you go.
Goodbye.
Angry no more.
There you go.
Oh my god, get over here.
You're the only surviving member left in the family.
Oh fuck, whoops.
It feels so different from the other realms.
It's warm, like Svartalfun.
But there's a kind of thing.
Press all the buttons.
Also, I need time to start processing the story.
My brain is like...
Not okay right now.
My brain is not awake at the moment, so give me a sec.
Alright, I have to go this way.
What's this?
Oh.
Oh, I could have used that in my fight.
It's still booting up, guys.
Don't worry, I have 10 hours.
I have 10 hours.
Yes, but also, because, like, dad kept waking me on and off
today, so that's why, like, I didn't get the best sleep.
Find the no-kid.
It's making these things stronger.
Wait, what's making these things stronger?
Oh, these... Oh, shit!
Okay, get out of here.
Get your ass out of here.
All right, there you are, little goblin.
That's fucking right.
You never fought in your life.
Okay.
But you never had a fight a real man.
Ha!
There we go.
Nice.
Oh my god, he's back.
Oh my god, he's back!
Behind you, incoming.
There you go.
Nice, he's dead.
How many are there?
Alright, now he's dead.
You get one of those watches that track your sleep?
It's just...
Normally I have good sleep.
It was just the fact that I kept sleeping and waking up,
sleeping and waking up, and that's not healthy.
But I can't do anything about it.
I have new neighbors.
It's nothing you could do.
You know, lad, this excursion into Vanahe means you've now
visited each of the nine realms.
Oh my god, I finally did it?
Guess you're right.
I didn't even realize...
Not many mortals can claim such a feat.
Not many gods either.
Even your father has yet to grace the halls of Asgard.
Usually it's fine.
Usually it's fine, but like, today was the...
It's just like, I hate... I hate that there's noise outside.
What if what if we're getting invaded?
Well, thank you.
Let's reach out.
Thank you.
Dragon eats you'll have to ask him for the full tail But I
take it that he like he's like to unite their people was
frowned upon wait Bayla's a dark elf.
Yes.
Wow Well, that raises even more questions Hope he's okay
Yeah, he was just like how dare you be outside my territory
like who are you uh joshua welcome to tell me welcome to
tomato farm welcome welcome what if they have treats for me
but can he even he can't welcome
like open up mom we're missing a prime real estate right now
behind me holy shit where the fuck oh my god are you fucking
kidding me oh my that's it oh never mind i was trying i was
smashing l3 i was smashing my rage button but apparently i
wasn't angry enough
all right where was that what the okay we're okay where am i
where did it load me into oh right here oh my god it's all
the way back here 11 hours
there you go
Okay, it's fine.
I can kill these guys.
Okay, buddy.
Okay.
Get out of here!
Alright.
That's right!
You think you can third party me?
Wait, what the fuck?
Wait, who's healing him?
Oh my god, that's what's healing him.
Oh my god, you little bitch.
You've never been in a real fight before, have you?
I was gonna say, excuse me.
How am I not doing any fucking damage?
There we go.
Get out of here.
That's it.
Goes angrily to sleep.
God, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, nice.
Got my loot.
What the fuck?
What are... Who is this squishy noises?
Here's squishy noises.
I don't like it.
Babe.
I should actually check if I can upgrade anything right now.
Oh yeah, no.
I have a lot of stuff to upgrade.
So I'm going to upgrade all of this.
My spear needs upgrades anyway.
Ah, fuck, okay.
Uh...
I got that.
Oh, that's the squishy noise.
Oh.
Oh, I'm sorry.
He's like, who did that?
Oh,
there's disturbed me.
It's alright, I can just stay here, I think.
That's fine, right?
Oh, he's just slowly.
Holy shit.
Oh, my God, it was not fine.
That must have been the win.
Okay, that's good.
there we go easy it's it's cool that he was slowly walking
towards me yeah I had a gun nice that's good that you know
he didn't really try to go to work I said it was for two
just walking menacingly office he which after our time with
the We've all had quite enough of but Odin still believes
that's got to be why the a nor you are stole the moon He's
still trying to avoid ragnarok or he prepares for it fights
a proxy war in this realm to distract his enemies Yeah All
right My not okay, I am What come on My thing is not that
short Come on!
There we go.
Oh my god, alright, let's...
Okay, and then we'll put one here.
Are you serious?
That should reach it, right?
There we go.
I was gonna say, come on, Credo's satisfied a lot of ladies.
It is, it's like above average at best.
or at worst where's the last one um above average there were
a lot of mini games apparently there were a lot of quick
time events
yeah he got the goddess of love
and she was happy also where the fuck is the last one I
swear I'm looking everywhere I guess hard to satisfy the
goddess of love when she had so so much experience it's the
last place you'll look okay alright Mr. Smart Guy
it's right there do you not Oh my god, it is right there.
Oh my god, the angle it.
Okay, chest unlocks.
Thank god for subtitles.
I cannot remember what it was.
Nice.
Just need two more.
Alright.
I guess we can go this way now.
I can sense them up there.
It's got to be their dead.
Excited to meet Skull and Hattie, lad.
I mean, I've heard all your stories.
It's going to be weird meeting them in person.
Legend meeting reality.
At the very least, it shouldn't fail to entertain.
Aphrodite was a sister.
I don't think it matters to gods at that point.
I don't think gods care about inbreeding.
Oh, they're the wolves that chase the moon.
Hello?
I think they're sleeping.
Well, there you have it the legendary so yeah They're so
cute as promised remember their shrine they didn't rejoin
the sky until after the moon returned.
There's no laws for the guys across the sky Right well best
we go find the moon and put it back where it belongs Hey as
if that's a perfectly normal thing to say
They seem really friendly Okay You gotta find the moon.
Patrick, welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
They like to do it like they do it in the Discovery Channel.
The Aynar Yarr played a part according to Skull and Hathi
Shrine.
I managed to stuff the moon inside a box.
If memory serves.
But it didn't say where they took the box.
Aye, that's the rub of using prophecy as a map.
it a bit sparse on the details there's a war camp in the
nearby village a strong fortress to guard their bounty we
will try there first all right let's go wait one last job
not much army really although beer girl was a soldier once
walking the path of a traveler almost got me with that
enormous broken sword of his a traveler that doesn't want to
kill us oh that's nice yeah that's pretty nice all right do
we need a no we just walk through here and then get this my
son apparently is immune to the poison oh yeah that must be
nice that that must be nice uh banana thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you i guess when you're immortal
and invincible race of god birth defects aren't a big deal
thank you the super You think you can just fix it or they'll
just they'll just banish them somewhere It's one or the
other they had to fix it or they're like I have no son
All right one last job We got to steal the moon Oh my god,
that's convenient All right
Get out of here!
That's my moon!
Oh shit, where the fuck did he come from?
That's right!
Arrows won't stop me!
Invisibility frame!
Alright, goodbye.
No, the wolves are grew.
I'm just stealing the moon back.
If anything, it's...
If anything, it's the other gods that are grew.
What the fuck?
How do I break this?
Cut?
I don't fucking remember.
I'm pressing circles.
What is this magic emblem?
can i burn it oh my god i had to walk backwards i i guess i
was too close i you're too close to the fucking prompt did
you see that that's a new enemy stay alert yeah correct
don't keep please it's not my fault i thought i could open
Open it closer!
Well, I do have to be further away to open a door.
Oh, there's the teleporting man.
Guess they know we're coming.
I can't believe no one's here.
They hide.
Devania aren't all hardened warriors like our- Yeah, now
they're plus one hour.
Once you survive the warfare, find it easier to hide in the
jungle and use nature as their shield.
It's like step one, we steal the moon.
Where the fuck?
It's not the way to go.
Unless there was another...
Oh, there's my white paint that my dead wife drew for me.
Because she knows me so well.
Step two, profit.
This wall, when I bring it down, we strike.
Let's see.
all right let's go we strike uh where'd they all go i don't
like all these stuff around me wait there's the moon down
there that's gotta be it that's the moon why is it so tiny i
don't think this is empty why are there health health and uh
anger juice all around me okay this is definitely an ambush
yes yes this is very ambush coded oh shit there he is there
we go oh wait he's not even an end boss they just teleport
now all right that's fine where though oh shit there you go
it's fine can't tell teleport from my fucking axe get out of
here all right where are the others that teleport this I got
a fucking it's like a journey to find them that's right you
feel so embarrassed now do you look I don't remember what
they're called I of the anger juice.
It makes me extra angry.
All right, there you go.
Whenever I drink it, I get extra mad.
Oh, fuck this.
I'll just start punching.
On the left.
What's he gonna do?
I'm angry.
I feel no pain no more.
I can't feel pain!
Oh my god, there's more?
Oh shit.
Wait, that's not why I wanted to use it on, but fine.
Yeah, it's like Popeye with my spinach.
Holy shit, there's...
Okay, they're pretty weak though, you're gonna ambush me at
least be strong enough for this I don't think Asgard's
running out of soldiers anytime soon You're gonna ambush me
at least be able to like finish the job.
That's just sad
All right, how do I get to the moon?
Oh Here ready to put the moon back where it belongs that is
a weird thing to say all right let's put the moon back
oh hey what the fuck she has the moon in her hands oh i'll
go find her a double ambush okay oh my god what is better
than one ambush two ambushes you see they're right i would
have never saw this coming I can't believe it.
Two ambushes?
That's crazy.
She's gone again.
I could have never expected it.
Oh my god, I gotta figure out how to do this.
Don't worry, so wait for me, right?
Yo, Doc, I heard you like ambush.
So we put an ambush in your ambush.
There!
oh shit oh nice I'm glad that it still hit him I was just
like alright nice I don't get up there oh she's still up
there oh it's another ambush oh it's like the poppy playtime
shit another chase sequence but difference between that and
a new chapter of poppy playtime is that this is an actual
good game
we're rescuing the moon yes i remember the prophecy so
doesn't it make you worried if everything we're doing now
happened in the yonar shrine remember our agreement prophecy
will not dictate our actions yeah our allies need help that
is our focus now Well, yeah, two per chapter, two ambush.
I'm trying to figure this out.
Where is the white paint?
It's down here, but why can't I go down?
Why did my wife not make it yellow?
Oh, my God.
My son, you were to go.
My son.
Why did it go down?
Why did you draw two?
My son is like, I'm father.
It's actually this way.
All right.
That's so nice of her to wait for me.
Make paint yellow again.
Whoa.
What is that?
Oh, I have a nasty beast.
Look at us all lives.
Oh, so my God.
It was that.
see oh my god he was right lightning what do you mean
lightning
all right i'll just slap him
angry wait actually yeah i'll beat up him first i'll beat up
your bird What the fuck is he gonna do to me?
I'm just so angry!
Oh shit, that is.
Bird fight!
Oh, I'm the better bird.
That's right.
Oh shit, he just...
just shielded herself again.
Well, it's good that she's just walking away menacingly.
giving me some extra training, I guess.
Well, that was nice of her to do that, honestly.
Alright.
Just letting me damage farm there.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thanks for letting me damage farm that.
Just boosting my stats, you know.
Alright, here's the moon why is the moon so tiny what
happened to it is this what happened to my moon not my moon
grab this while I freed Garm yeah it's talented it's not big
enough for two birds and now you fight to undo the damage
your guilt is misplaced yeah no you're right I know I just
couldn't be Why take time to chuck multiple spears when I
can just stab her in front of me.
I take my time to aim it.
She's literally in front of me.
I can just stab her.
Oh yeah, I grew shrunk it.
Sorry, I forgot.
Zeus shrunk the moon.
Doubt is a weakness we cannot afford.
Who said anything about doubt?
So far, we've done everything the giant said we would.
We make our own choices.
Yeah, but we chose to make those decisions.
Not because the Giants told us.
Sorry, that was Zeus.
Oh, yeah, I got it.
Oh, shit.
I met Odin.
Sorry, all the the godfathers blurred together for me today.
There you go.
Oh, what the fuck?
Wait, where's my... alright, there you go.
I'm gonna stay.
Alright, get out of here.
Trying to ambush me.
But what if...
Why doing all this?
What if we're walking straight into Ragnarok?
Isn't there any way to avoid fate?
You can never avoid fate, son.
What if we can't stop you from...
Would you turn your back on the wolves?
On this realm?
Remember our agreement.
We let it happen.
If it happens, it happens.
It's just destiny.
What the fuck?
Boy, you lead me here.
Oh, it's here.
I was like, boy, where do we go?
The lad does make some good points, though.
As long as Atreus lives, so be it.
My son will carry on my destiny.
And I'm pretty sure...
I'm pretty sure Kratos is so fucking tired.
The only way he can retire is just to die, which is pretty
sad, but like...
retirement oh there's the moon
yeah oh there's an eclipse it's a solar eclipse
there's beautiful if
i do this wait only bind you if you let it do what is
necessary Guys, we should be looking into the center of the
eclipse, guys.
We're going to put our fancy sunglasses.
Did no one teach you this in science 101?
Oh, they're going to chase it now.
Chasing the sun away.
Yay!
The moon's back.
Now we get nighttime.
They got the god eyes.
They have a gift for us.
A way to call them anytime we need them.
Oh.
So anytime I want it to be day or nighttime.
I wonder if that changes the, like, the pathways or
something.
Feels like they want us to use it at one of the altars.
Oh, that's what the altars are for.
Perhaps Freya will know.
So in essence, they just gave us the keys.
keys of dust till dawn not bad for a day's work that makes
sense i was gonna say what what was what would be the point
of changing from night and day much change to like the game
environment or something like the pathways i don't think can
we pet the wolf i'll try i want to pet the wolf i assume i
can't because he's sleeping he's trying to eat no we can't
You can't pet the wolf, guys.
9 out of 10.
Can't pet the big wolf.
Yeah, I was going to say.
I'm pretty sure they don't want me to wake up the dog.
This place changes that night.
I knew it.
How does it...
No less humid, unfortunately.
I knew it changes.
Makes sense.
Oh, shit!
Oh, my God.
I'm getting poisoned.
He's poisoning me.
I am mashing circle.
How is he so strong?
All right Okay, maybe I don't like nighttime Maybe oh my god
a fucking course All right, that's fine You know what fuck
this Yep, still very very eager What the fuck?
Liking it less.
Yeah, I'm liking it less, too.
I agree.
I'm just gonna...
Come on, just slowly.
Alright, nice.
I'm gonna get there eventually.
Another ambush in my ambush in my ambush game?
No.
They come back fast, but not that fast.
You can ask guard.
at six ambush one well all these in here you are we've been
fighting they've already died in battle once they're just
bringing them back i'm here and they'll just wake back up
and yeah never truly die should it come to war we do well to
have our own endless army of dead soldiers you mean
hellheim's army like the prophecy said it will not come to
that oh what the fuck two of them Oh my god.
Me too.
I'm like, what do you mean two of them?
Oh my god, what the fuck?
How are they back?
I just killed them!
Did I not?
I swear I killed these guys!
Okay, at least they're giving me an actual fair.
Okay, never mind.
I was gonna say, at least they're giving me a 1v1.
And then he was like, nope.
There's more?
Okay, nice.
Oh, that's not what I wanted.
That's fine.
There we go.
I'm just going to beat you up now.
Oh, fuck.
I didn't mean to...
Oh, shit down!
There we go.
Yeah, try to die, me!
Try to die!
Please support!
I've got the experience!
Oh, whoa.
Okay, maybe you got that, though.
There we go.
Get out of here.
I'm gonna say this, the whole clan wants me dead.
Alright, let's kill him.
Ever since I killed their dad.
That's why you gotta end the bloodline.
You got killed the entire family, so no one will want
revenge.
All right, I should have enough for upgrades, right?
Oh, shit, nice.
I do have enough.
Thank God, finally a heavy attack.
Wait, Hydra charge.
Oh, yeah, I wanted the thrust.
The thrust one is a lot better.
We're gonna need to upgrade more of this.
uh range oh yeah we gotta get that might as well upgrade the
other stuff Arteus I'm pretty sure you have upgrade for days
oh yeah 100% forgot about you yeah no yeah you did have
upgrade for days I'm sorry daddy was going through a lot
All right, where am I going here?
We report back to Hilda's Feeney.
Then what?
We came here to help Freya.
We will not leave without rescuing her brother and the
lighthouse.
Okay, but Odin's not going to stop searching for mask
pieces.
That is his concern.
Not ours.
Sure.
But if that mask offers all the answers...
Then it will surely exact a price.
Be wary of shortcuts to knowledge.
Yes, father.
All right.
I'll grab this chest, though.
Yay!
Luke!
I love Luke.
Oh, actually, that returns.
Kratos is fully protected with it.
Yeah, but it's not damage.
Me only want damage!
Hey, sometimes short-term damage.
haircut is good we're spider not harder okay wait how do I
fuck do I get back here
all right down we go bunga bunga damage why stun when I can
kill them faster
stunning is just delaying damage
where the fuck is it he knew it I was drinking my water oh
fuck it little poison was hurt anyone all the plants you
want to kill us oh no only the carnaptious ones well i see
you i fucking see you over there just sitting there
menacingly thinking i'll just walk up to you all right we
should be back to the camp now
whoo whoo whoo whoo who's there look at barks that wrinkly
mug belongs to halka yeah is that the dog hounds prized for
their pinpoint accurate tracking abilities it's the it's the
pig dog yeah don't need someone they don't breathe no more
thank you for coming big vir use the diversion to escape
what about your brother we know that they're holding him now
bail has already prepped the explosives if you're with me we
can leave as soon as you're ready me ready i could use
another shapeshift to help go with him andreas I will aid
Freya.
Yes, sir.
Alright.
Let's see.
Once you see the signal count it down.
Okay, I was gonna say do I have do I have any upgrades?
Do I have any upgrades?
Nope.
Oh, I do here.
Oh, it was red.
The fire blades.
Hmm.
I feel like all my other stuff is already pretty strong.
Yeah.
Ooh, except for this.
Wait.
Runic 22.
5th defense.
Vitality.
It does take my runic down.
I do get vitality.
I have zero.
You're going to fuck it.
Let's try it.
Did not get that.
I thought I equipped it.
Okay, I did not...
I didn't automatically equip it.
I was so confused.
It's fine.
I want to keep my runic up.
I really like my runic damage there.
And Lady Freya?
Yeah, sorry.
I'm no money for you.
What else was there?
Oh, hi.
Yeah, your little one.
well he's a cutie pie should have seen him a couple winners
ago ain't even at eye level no more oh you hush ain't
nothing wrong with a growing boy yeah my son is still
growing he's gonna be big and tall and strong like this old
man i mean we're two job woman job man gonna make a job boy
I mean, um, right.
You are holding fear in your father's own temple.
It's been empty for as long as I can remember.
There's a celestial altar across the river.
According to Big Veer, the altars were once used to signal
the wolves.
And now we have just the scepter to do it.
What is your plan?
When we reach the temple, I'll fire off the beacon.
A signal for Veila and Birger to set off their distraction.
elf hive nice to not be on the receiving end of it for once
with their attention drawn elsewhere you and i can assault
the main force from behind while atreus and hildesfini slip
in to rescue your brother in the confusion yes once we see
their beacon we'll regroup by the river and escape on
frayer's boat is it because i'm listening to the plot okay
yeah i was gonna say why can't i beach this boat she's like
quiet
Oh my god, they're reproducing.
There you go.
Get over here.
Oh my god.
Did you miss?
How did you miss?
It was right there.
Oh shit.
Whatever
That's right Dodge this Can't start my blade Shitty ghost
That's right Imagine being a ghost but not see-through
She was nervous.
Say, it was like point blank.
And she still missed.
Fucking ass.
Oh my god, she's just blocking me.
What's she gonna do?
Just chuck that.
Alright, give me a say.
Like, I can't do shit.
Oh my god, okay.
Fuck this.
I'm just gonna go over here.
Okay, I like that.
A fucking kick.
A grab kick.
Get out of here.
It's stupid.
That's fucking right.
Get out of here.
What the fuck is that?
How did I get here?
Oh my god.
I did not sign up for this.
Okay, there I have one.
Oh my god, I still have one more.
Okay, I can still be angry.
That's right.
Oh my god, he's like, he went all the way over here.
I knew I had one more enemy wait where is he he's not taking
oh my god a fucking course that's right I'm gonna say what
do you mean he's not taking damage oh no this is not good
this is not good
oh my god there's more of them No!
He has support.
Fuck.
I just use it to heal the smiling rage.
Oh my god, I have to do that all over again.
Not fair, they called reinforcements!
Where's my reinforcements?
I'm getting my brother back.
You're under no obligation to help me.
I know.
I don't need Resurrection Stone.
no pussy when I die I die I don't need magic to save a run
oh
my god where's the support okay he's not the support yeah oh
fuck oh
my Oh my god, that's the guy with the support.
What the fuck?
Okay, it's fine.
I don't need magic's help.
Where the fuck is that pussy?
I can't do shit to this!
Oh my god, there you are.
That's where you were hiding!
Get out of here!
There you go.
Oh my god, he actually...
He actually dodged that.
All I do is just need those hands!
Wait, that's my spear.
There you go.
Alright, stabby stabby!
I have... Oh, I do.
I said... Fireball!
Fireball!
There you go.
Easy.
See, I told you!
I don't need death to fight.
I'm ready to fight death!
With these bare hands!
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh, wait.
I I wanted to grab that heal.
Bad support.
Please report.
Oh my god, not these guys again.
That Noken's healing his friend, Donna.
Oh my god.
There's another healer.
There's a support somewhere.
Where is he?
Oh, there.
You thought you could hide from me?
I'm fucking right.
Okay, that's awkward.
That's very awkward.
It's okay.
Oh my god, there's another one!
Where is he?
Oh my god, where is he?
There's another one.
Where is he?
I thought I killed both of you already.
Oh, where the fuck did he go?
I hear his calls.
Oh my god, he's up here, isn't he?
I hear him.
I hear him calling.
Where the fuck is he?
I hear him calling the sound.
Kimrish don't look up.
I don't.
Please, I'm trying to figure out where he is.
Meow, meow.
Oh my god, he's hiding in there!
Fucking bitch!
Oh my god.
There we go.
So I can finally use that.
I can't believe it.
Fucking he was like goddamn racket rocket raccoon right
there.
Yeah, but you're hiding up in the bushes Bro W support L DPS
not peeling for support
It's like I hear your sounds I hear your singing where are
you try dragging the scepter across the bell a few times
Is it sun time?
Yeah!
Come on.
We're making good time.
Sun time.
I don't even know what it changes, technically.
Everything looks the same.
It's just night.
It's like an Overwatch map.
Our actions in this realm followed the prophecy of the
giants.
Atreus believes Ragnarok is inevitable.
The Norns were quite clear on the nature of prophecy.
They told us the sum of our choices were predictable.
But we have changed, haven't we?
They keep doing it.
They'll just...
Oh, do it again?
Oh, really?
Alright, let's try it.
Oh, do the roots change?
Oh, that's what it does.
Am I good?
Alright.
What the fuck?
Why was this guy there?
I see what are you doing the bridge only grows in the
daylight I I wanted to see the wolves oh that's cute run for
me okay you've seen them now call back hottie and let's go
that's funny oh yeah it's growing it's like when They're
like, I don't want a dog.
Because then I have to take care of the dog.
I don't want another dog.
And then you get another dog.
And he's like, I love him.
That's cute.
He does have a soft side.
The true dad right of passage.
A true dad moment.
Where kid wants a dog.
And you end up taking care of the dog.
And now it's your dog.
And you won't have it anymore.
other way oh goodbye
that's fine holy shit he's just all spears yeah you guys
want to see a firework
whoops i thought it would be further
There we go.
Oops, all spheres.
The Norn said you'd kill Heimdall, but you chose not to walk
that path.
Well, not yet.
When we first met, I doubt you'd have done the same.
And you?
Do you still seek Ragnarok?
Odin has much to answer for.
If Groa's prophecy is correct, perhaps my realm can finally
know peace.
Perhaps I can know peace.
Forgive me for being ahead on a belt, but haven't we all
just...
established how prophecy is pure Havos.
God's the mere.
What?
The most annoying man alive.
Is that his prophecy?
Alright.
Oops.
Alright, we're gonna have to do the thing again.
That prolongs it, right?
Oh, yeah, that does.
Oh, nice.
Wait, if that's the right path then what is this path i knew
it stupid flower oh i was already here wait what i was
already here
all right nice
all the bushes blur together for me
All right, nice.
Can't believe the plants grew back.
More up ahead.
On your mark.
Oh, he's waiting for me.
That's nice.
Or like, we want a fair fight.
We might be evil.
We're not monsters.
All right.
Whoops.
Oh, shit.
Actually, I saved it for that.
to your left.
All right.
It's time.
Spear time!
There we go.
That's right.
Oh shit.
That's fine.
I could do this.
I can always get angry.
If all I have spells, I can always always get angry.
See?
Okay, this one's almost done.
What?
Where did he go?
I was just like, oh, wait.
Fire.
Alright, nice.
Easy.
Anger solves every problem.
Oh.
What I learned.
backwards.
There's the how I can't do that up close.
Oh.
Do that.
Give us me extra loot.
I knew it.
Can't hide from me, Mr. Loot Box.
Loot.
Yeah.
Money.
Oh, $100?
Holy shit.
Someone's trying to hide their life savings in the barrel.
Well, my barrel.
Oh, it's that guy I'll get.
That's the alpha.
Tough fight.
I know pussy.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Actually, let me play here first and then you freeze it and
then, all right.
Oh, oh, oh, he has his own name.
Oh, oh, oh, that might have been a mistake.
Oh, oh, oh.
It's okay, it's okay.
I have all the powers.
Okay, it's okay.
I have this.
And I have this.
And then.
And then I can do this.
Oh, God.
That's not a lot.
That's...
Oh, my God.
Let's get it.
We're doing a lot of damage, though.
We're making progress.
There we go.
It's good.
We're making a lot of progress.
Oh, shit.
We're still making...
We're still...
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
We almost got it.
Oh.
I wanted to use my ice move, but he killed me before I
could.
This will be at ease.
See first, famous, last words.
And she did warn y'all.
Okay, it's fine.
And then...
Spear, spear, spear, spear, spear, spear!
And then, sis!
And then!
and then i said one more oh my god that hits me
what that hits me again okay i'm glad that he waited are you
okay oh i don't know do you really think i am okay right now
don't think so.
I don't feel okay right now.
Holy shit.
No.
Okay.
Oh my god.
There we go.
Yes.
Second try.
All right.
Alpha, this.
That was the alpha.
Damn.
I guess the women weren't satisfied if that was the alpha
the women settled for sure all right see i told you guys i
got this yeah all right here we go down we go this way all
right open the door
And that's where we killed the mom.
Let's ask how we made the kids into orphans.
I don't doubt it.
Curious though.
What was she doing here?
Odin used roots of the world tree as part of his spell that
kept me from leaving Midgard.
Nithhoke protects the tree's roots wherever they are.
Yeah, I beat the alpha so they're my bitches now.
And she unwittingly paid the price.
All right, girl.
Odin.
Now her kids are orphans!
Oh my god.
Okay, we gotta angle this right.
Is that straight?
See ya.
The northern wild.
Okay, we need HP.
We're so fucked up.
From that fight.
If she was a single mother, there was no dad.
If we distract them long enough, Hilda Spini and Atreus will
have more than enough time to get in and out undetected.
There's a hardworking single mother.
Odin promised her that she could...
that she would never have to worry about money again if she
does that one last job.
Alright.
Oh, he said her kids and her will be taken care of if she
does this last job.
Wait, they're not access this?
Oh, I have to do it back here.
Are you ready?
I am.
Are you?
I'm not leaving here.
No, the squirrel is like the stepfather.
The one that stepped up.
He was always in love with her.
Oh?
What?
And the day he confessed to her, she went out to do Oda's
last job.
So she and her kids will finally be safe for their new
stepfather.
The squirrel.
We're coming for you, Invi.
It's time?
I don't like this.
This looks like an arena.
Oh, shit!
Oh, my.
My god is Heimdall.
What idiots?
Oh.
If it isn't Queen Missletoe myself.
If I have no thoughts while fighting him, he can't predict
this.
Been a while.
Heimdall.
Oh my god, the prophecy was right.
You must be the little half-breed's father.
Um, he is not little.
Lucky day.
to answer for sunshine you too traitor better a traitor than
orden's lap dog hmm
bro the burden is mine I can help but
you are needed elsewhere he's right you know sizzles wasn't
looking so hot last I saw I know you didn't want this but we
know how this ends I kill him so you soon.
That's good.
Prophecy already said I'm going to kill you anyway, so it's
going to happen.
You and your brother, as soon as I am finished here.
Oh, I am watching it.
Don't worry.
I was eating my mochi donuts.
Watch this!
Oh, you didn't expect that, did you?
That's right!
Oh!
Oh, did you expect this?
Wow!
Oh, that's right.
What about this?
Oh my god!
Or this!
You didn't expect all of this, right?
How about this?
And then this!
And that!
And then I don't know what to do now.
And what about this?
But you didn't expect all of this!
That's right.
I bet you didn't.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Bro, what the fuck?
Let me fight you.
There!
Oh, fuck!
What the fuck?
Yeah, I'm killed your steed.
Let's go!
You wasn't right about you.
Yeah, you and me then that's right.
Oh fuck he expected that wait, I don't understand how did
he?
How did he expect that way out wait Who wait I don't
understand how did he expect it?
For the reason Oh shit, oh you didn't expect that
I can feel your frustration now.
It is immensely satisfying.
What now, brother?
The spear remains our best chance.
Oh, wait.
You expected the stick to give you...
Yeah, can you dodge all of that?
He dodged all of that.
He dodged, guys, he dodged all of it.
Guys, he dodged all of it.
You are already prolonging all of this.
Guys, he dodged all of it, guys.
Guys, he...
he got oh okay watch this there you go oh oh there okay okay
oh there okay
I can see why the half-breed is such a pushover.
Oh, you didn't expect that, did you?
That's right.
Wait, but did you expect this?
Hey, careful.
These are new braces.
Oh, shit.
That's right.
Never expect the ground.
Ha, ha, ha, ha.
Okay.
Oh,
my God.
Okay.
That's right.
Oh, my God.
I'm trying to use my spear, but then...
Oh, I got him!
That's right.
I did.
Oh.
Oh, that's awkward.
I don't remember the last time anyone Hits me.
Oh shit.
Oh shit
Oh my god, I swear to God.
I pressed it.
Oh my god Oh my god stop you have a lot of nerve.
You know that slow it down Okay, there you go
oh please please yes please no
oh i can hit him now okay okay i got paranoid i was trying
to i think and he knew i was thinking that's right that's
right now you're vulnerable because you're angry
Let that anger flow!
Oh, what?
His was first?
There we go.
Slow down.
Oh, God.
I'm pressing...
Dodge!
There we go.
Oh, God.
There you go.
There we go.
Armor fits for a cut.
It's fine.
Here you go.
What the fuck I dodged!
There we go.
I don't understand.
How are you predicting my move?
Oh, JK, you can!
Am I dodging?
What?
I'm not dodging!
Okay.
No, he's not.
is there we go are you fucking kidding me are you oh my god
are you
oh my god you fuck
Get over here!
Come on!
No!
Oh my gosh!
One HP in a dream!
That's right!
Slow this!
That's all this is!
It's not luck!
It's called Brain Empty Ungabunga No thoughts Just stab
I didn't kill him!
She didn't do the prophecy.
Wait.
What is going on in that empty head?
Diane!
Let's try it.
It works.
Let me out of pity.
What's going on that empty head?
Is this about the little runt?
Oh, now I am definitely going to gut him.
Oh, my God.
No!
This is your final warning.
How can one read when one has no thoughts?
You think you get to just walk away?
He truly is the god of rage baiting.
That is not how this works.
What the fuck?
He could just throw another arm?
You do not get to decide my fate.
You are dead, sunshine.
Wait, what?
That's not...
That's cheating.
Wait, what?
What do you mean?
I wouldn't be!
Missile toe is long gone.
It's just you and me.
That is not fair.
That is actually not fair!
I have one HP!
Way over your head!
What the fuck?
Don't you know who I am?
Oh no.
I am the watchman of the AC.
Bro, I have one HP.
I have one HP.
I have one HP right now.
has like he literally got his all his hp back i this is not
fair
okay there we go now it's fair okay now it's fair okay
eventually he's gonna step into my spear right Oh, come on!
Oh,
this is bad.
I don't think we're winning this one.
We're not winning this one.
Oh my god, this is bad.
Oh, this is so bad.
I am the watchman of the ASEAN, the herald of Ragnarok.
Oh, fuck!
Oh, goodbye.
No, I'm just gonna, I'm restarting.
Okay, over here, I'll let you grab me for fun.
Patro has to think of a super chat thing.
She's so fished, even though she did two parries back to
back.
Snap!
Bear!
Me first.
There you go.
Way over your head.
Okay, I have me first.
Don't you know who I am?
Are you fucking?
Okay, there we go.
I am the watchman of the AC.
Oh my god.
The arrows of Ragnarok.
Fuck.
He punched me!
I am going to find that little mongrel of yours and beat his
face into a...
Okay, there we go.
All right, there we go.
Oh, fuck, what the fuck?
Okay, there we go.
I'll grab this real quick
Bro, he's so why are you so mad What a cat fucking okay,
that's dare you try and spare me there you go There you All
right I am growing very sickly.
Holy shit.
Oh my god, I could have.
Okay, I didn't realize that was a move.
All right, nice.
There you go.
Oh my god.
Nice.
Here you go.
Spirit time!
Holy shit, what the fuck?
He just...
He just tanked all that.
Oh, you bitch.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
If he gets closer, I can hit him.
Go, get closer.
Get closer.
Yeah, get closer.
Yeah, run into my sphere.
That's right.
Stop!
Stop the prophecy, brothers!
This isn't who you want to be.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
Oh yeah, no, he's gonna die.
Unless...
Oh.
Wait.
It was a joke.
Oh.
It was just a prank, bro.
Rev.
Do something.
Oh, no.
It was just a prank.
Kratos!
He's just sleeping.
It's all good.
Kratos.
I was just...
I don't know if we are breaking fate.
Or fate's breaking us.
no I chose this it was my choice guys it was my choice I
feel satisfied have I proved the Norns right or have I
proved them right guys no I chose this took the faith didn't
choose this I chose this guys he deserved it exactly he
deserved it he reached beta 2 close to the Sun oh my we're
so good
that's right he wanted this guys
i didn't get rage baited into killing him
oh the new relic which one oh this oh shit oh it's the how
do i use my relic again oh it's the oh right oh it's the
freeze no no no i didn't follow i created my own prophecy
guys right i chose this guys no he didn't read i i picked
this it's the circle one yeah i was gonna say
what do we learn today chat chat shit get killed They give
us a super chat.
Thank you.
Guys, be careful who you rage bait.
You might die.
You might get murdered.
Hey, a little help.
At least the rescue's going well.
At least we got them.
Time and place, Mimir.
Time and place.
Not ready for your smart ass right now.
What the fuck?
boy where's my stuff wait this is the oh wait i'm using the
wrong one that's i just noticed the ice i was like wait a
minute that's ice oh my god is this another ambush
oh my god who would have expected ambush.
Who could have expected that?
Alright.
We gotta get over there.
Get over here.
You thought you could run away just because you have a
shield?
What a surprise!
Another ambush.
in my ambush game?
Okay, I'm gonna wait for them to come up.
I'm gonna come up so I can use this.
Bam!
Oh shit, that was sick, though.
Oh, and then the slam stun!
Holy fuck!
Okay, that's that's for ya.
Whoops.
What the fuck?
That was a fucking block!
I definitely blocked that.
There we go.
Now that's a block.
Oh my god.
I can't get down.
I can't jump down from here.
Oh, there's another one.
Okay, apparently I missed.
Oh, where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Oh, shit.
Not expect that guy here.
All right, it's fine.
Oh, it's fine.
Because then I can do this!
Okay, he is not getting stunned by any of my...
That's crazy.
He's not getting stunned by anything.
Holy...
There you go.
Yeah, I was gonna say, what the fuck?
Oh my god, are you fucking kidding me?
That travels there?
There we go.
Yeah, a helmet not protecting you from your own fucking
weapon.
Grabbing this.
Yeah, they might need a bigger helmet.
I'm heading over.
Try?
No, sit tight.
We'll figure something out.
I will carry you.
That's right.
Get on my back.
No homo.
Come on.
You cannot.
Ow.
Easy.
To me.
Follow.
We, uh, got company back here.
Wait, what am I?
Oh, shit!
Oh, that's what it is.
I was like...
Okay.
All right.
R1 is left!
What would happen anyway?
It's not like I'm gonna die.
Oh, seriously?
It's not gay, it's just the prophecy.
Hey,
I'm a train.
You okay?
Hi.
No.
Just hold on.
All right, get out of here.
Holy shit.
This chasing is sick though.
We gotta be close, right?
On your right!
Oh, it's the elves!
Oh,
shit.
It's a portable boat.
I'm like, that's paper.
Oh!
Freya's boat They will regroup We should go That's cool
Horgami boat I need a hero Bam bam Bam bam bam
It does fit that song
You know I realize what he looks like He looks like what's
his name something lead The guy who was in oh my gosh this
is going to be a very old tv show but the pushing daisies
guy i don't know if anyone knows that show that show was so
i used to watch that show growing up with my mom and then
they canceled it i was so sad but he looks like that main
character guy from pushing daisies lee pace yeah his face
looks like lee pace i was so sad when that show was canceled
i think it's the eyebrows eyebrows because he has like
really thick eyebrows it was such a it was such a quirky
show it was so whimsical like the writing was so weird but
it was like very interesting relax oh my god we're flying
yeah the one with the pie it's flying we're flying a fucking
cliffhanger, too.
I knew it would do that.
I like how nobody told them.
Like, everyone knew except for Kratos and Arteus.
I can show you the world.
I was going to say, yeah, it looks like a flying boat.
It looks like a ghost boat.
It's going to be so funny when they realize we're not going
to die.
That would mean when we're Oh, there's another one.
We passed the waterfall.
This was going too smoothly.
Uh, little help.
Look out.
Another, is this like a, oh my God.
Who would have thought?
It's an ambush.
Another chasey and my poppy slate tab.
Another ambush and my god of war.
Oh, is he gonna sacrifice himself?
No, don't do it.
I don't know who you are.
We just met.
No!
To witness me.
Burger,
no!
Burger, no!
Witness me!
Holy fuck.
Don't worry, there's water under there, right?
His name was actually Burger.
Wait, who's going to take care of the dog?
I just read- What about his dog?
Burger, my favorite character who had only two minutes of
screen time.
What about his dog?
No corpse means he's still true.
We didn't see his corpse, guys.
Damn it, Pyrrha.
I really think that's the end of Pyrrha.
You think he survived that?
He's down there picking the dirt out of his nails with the
beast's feathers.
We'll see.
Oh, no, he's coping.
Oh, no.
He's in denial.
He has to be.
We're almost there, Invy.
just hold on a bit longer I don't suppose I had much of a
choice at the moment he was my best man don't worry there's
no fall damage in cutscenes that's true it's like Doomfist
stage one is denial
Lunda Lunda we need cloth and boiling water red root and
lambscrest I know I know you think I never staunch a bleeder
before oh Now don't you go worrying, boss.
I didn't go through any of your stuff while you was off
being tortured.
Ah!
Damn it!
Lunda!
Easy.
Heck you say this to me for!
I'm the one who stuck you like a damn pig.
No offense.
Freya, mind giving her a hand?
We're just taking over entirely?
Hold still.
She'll just get you stable so I can take you to Sindri's
house.
The rest of my herbs are there.
We'll protect the realm in your absence.
The four of us.
Vanaheim's in good hands.
Part of its injuries, huh?
Whoever that is.
Your boat.
Your forgotten.
My boat!
Come on, take it.
Sail the skies.
Sun yourself on its bow.
You look like you could use it.
Make a Vanier God proud.
Hey, the elves are alive.
alive at least.
Forbidden love still prospered.
Because it was necessary.
Not because it was written.
Exactly.
I chose to kill him.
I agree.
Prophecy holds a galahorn as the herald of Ragnarok.
Whatever it does.
Read about it and known as Lyra.
Supposedly it.
Hold it, Dreyus.
us in private all right we have any upgrades oh nice okay um
defense vitality vitality you know what fuck it that's
craftable and it gives me vitality okay i'll equip it too oh
i can upgrade this yeah fuck it let's upgrade
what happened to the dog i want to keep the runic because i
feel like the runic is pretty good already
i can upgrade this or i can
runic does go up by lose you know i'm gonna upgrade this you
won't get so much as a paper cut in that all right is there
anything else
right we should get wait feels like there was something else
it was hard doll is dead good is it look i don't know from
faith but i know heimdall was a prize-winning can't stain
with that no one even liked him boy it's a good thing he
ain't around no more that's crazy
shut-in spinsters ain't worth a goat fart in a hurricane you
did what you did no need to fret about it he was an asshole
but he was hot though he was a hot asshole
all right
um hey joke you're gonna do some side missions to get better
equipment to stream Stop it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I think... Well, it depends on, like, if the side quest does
give me actual good shit.
Good to see you again, Kratos.
Have you been back to Alphine by any chance?
Big Veer.
Now is not the time.
All right.
Nearly forgot about that.
It was something to be mentioned.
All right.
Oh, yeah.
No, that's a lot of shit I did not do.
It's just upgraded fully.
Oh, that's not creepy.
I never thanked him.
If you want to thank him, don't get captured again.
I promise.
I promise, love.
That's right.
You don't want to lose that baddie.
Oh.
I hear the dog barking.
Wait, where's the dog barking coming from?
Oh.
That's so sad.
What does that mean?
Wait, does that mean he's alive?
could be important maybe wait it could be important wait he
might be alive i think he smells her or she smells him
tracks where do you go
where are you leading this girl yeah where the is she
leading us so what do you want to do now we don't have to go
straight home do we look seems we're on the right path where
is she now hey girl we're here I lost track of her I guess
we should follow her the tracks go here
because that doesn't lead me anywhere okay it's okay our
chase knows where he is more paw prints little slumber balls
quite the tracker why are we using the new boat I don't know
how to use are my new boat.
I don't know how to bring it out.
What the fuck?
Oh.
Alright.
They're packed back for round two.
Did you not learn anything?
Oh my god.
Boy, I need you to shoot him.
There we go.
It's this way.
More of Helka's tracks.
I dare say she's got a skill to know for hunting is you
brother hers is superior the eyes could lie the nose cannot
woof that make you wish you could turn into an animal every
once in a while woof woof no and there she goes all right
I'm going as fast as I can boy now you remember how to get
back here too because I definitely don't remember
okay nice they're not getting healed that's what i like to
see that's right no supports
all right let's get him out of here too all right get that
rage meter ah she went over that ridge okay we are calling
the day daytime daytime
All right, boy, do you want to see the wolves?
Look at the wolves.
We're coming, Elka.
Can't be far now.
The fuck, okay.
The game was like, well, still down there.
We can still processing textures.
Oh, hey, Reed.
Wait, Beager?
I knew it.
We didn't see nobody.
I knew he was alive.
Never doubted for a second.
Oh, hey, there's the boat.
Burger is still alive.
Saving private burger.
That's a nice, quiet trip.
No one wants to talk.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Magic, perhaps.
Let's make sure to ask.
Skill diff.
He's just built different, bro.
Maybe he landed on a bunch of trees.
Oh, you know, there was like a survival story where, like,
someone fell from the plane.
And then they survived because they landed on all the bushes
and the trees and the vines and stuff that cushioned the
fall.
Physics!
Maybe, maybe he had a water bucket.
Well, he seemed angry.
What do you suppose that means?
We are going the right way.
Where are we anywhere?
Looks to be the ruins of a once thriving Vanier settlement.
What happened?
You don't rightly know.
He parried the ground.
Oh, hey.
Oh, nice.
of money just lying around the fuck there's a gateway in the
middle of all this
well shouldn't i be exploring this first oh it's over here
wow it's nice that my wife knew i was gonna head here too oh
what the fuck that signal jigger's alive not for long if
that dragon yeah i was gonna sit i was John ass dragon Yeah,
it's frozen.
That's weird one made in my fight with Thor But why would
everyone just like it here in Vanaheim?
Oh my god.
Is Thor here?
That's a good question
Fuck it Don't use my magic The dragon's back and it's angry.
Oh shit He's not gonna oh my god Fucking course.
Oh my god.
He's third party That's illegal.
Don't make me throw this at you.
That's okay.
He doesn't care He really does not care.
Are you fucking kidding me?
I'm just trying to grab an item retreat tactics Just parry
the fire It doesn't like us invading its territory
shit oh okay I'm actually have to start raging all right
nice oh my god I can't punch this I was gonna say I'll just
punch this but I can't it's okay I can punch him though
Okay, that's five.
Spear!
Get stabbed!
That's right!
And it gets stabbed again!
There you go.
Oh my god, I'm too far.
Okay, he'll get closer to me, right?
That's awkward.
That's pretty awkward.
There you go.
Time stop!
Boom!
There we go.
Pre-kill.
Free loot!
Oh, okay, I was gonna say, um...
What did I just do?
How are we gonna get to Birger?
His head is still attached.
What the fuck happened?
Yeah, you just go walk into my blade, right?
I knew it.
fucking course that hits me why are they laughing at me yeah
fuck you oh my god there's a support here isn't that
interesting what is it having a clue hence the interest
still crystals are valuable perhaps we'll find a use for it
is this time
No, it's not.
Where's the last one?
Oh, it is time.
Wait, where's the third one?
I see two.
Oh, over there.
Don't know.
Really?
Maybe if we came back at night, they'll change somehow.
Yeah.
Maybe I can grip this here.
No, I can't.
Oh my god, I just missed it.
I fucking just missed it.
Does it connect?
Oh my god, where does it go?
Okay.
One, two, three, one, two, three.
Does it connect?
I can't tell.
I can't tell from here.
Oh my god.
Is it too far?
What if I can go over there?
Huh.
How do I even get over there?
Oh my god, he's coming back.
Guys, can I hit it from here?
Or, like, is that impossible?
Oh yeah, it's definitely not connecting.
Maybe, like, if I connect it here, maybe.
oh my god yeah no it's not connecting at all unless yeah
fuck yeah i give up there might be a way to get up there i
just don't know yet and why is there tornado here
yeah i should just be able to use my flying boat am i is he
stupid or some shit
I know I could burn this.
What's that?
What the fuck?
Hello.
What the fuck, bro?
That's fucked.
Just minding my own business.
Oh my god.
What is he doing here?
There we go.
Let's just beat this guy up in the corner.
That's right!
Oh my god, where are you?
Wait, where did he go?
He just...
Okay.
He's right beneath me, isn't he?
I'm trying to go beneath me.
Oh, my God.
Get out of here!
That's right.
Should have stuck your fucking tail out.
Huh.
I wonder what they were guarding.
Oh, it's just like a...
Like a little compass here for the objective.
For this objective.
Because I am confused.
Oh, wait.
I didn't open this chest.
Oh, there's another chest.
There's so much loot around here.
Yeah, this is a very big area.
I thought I was just here to get burger.
Wait, can I actually?
Where's the one about...
There's nothing for a burger.
I don't see one for a burger.
Holy shit.
Like, where am I?
Like, actually.
Actually, where the fuck am I?
That's their loot.
Does he know?
Oh, he knew.
I- oh shit!
What the fuck?
I was gonna send!
Oh, he- oh!
Oh, okay.
Oh my!
What the...
What the fuck?
Oh, I don't like that.
So, like, he doesn't get stunned, guys.
Oh, Jesus Christ.
I thought he would get stunned, but I guess not.
Okay.
Yeah, he's locked in.
He's locked.
Okay, I thought he would get stunned.
But it was just me, like, just looking.
Or I can angle it.
I don't even know if I did any damage on that.
I...
Yeah.
That's not fair.
That's actually not fair.
Oh my god.
What is...
I was like in the middle of my cutscene.
He's just standing there.
There.
Jesus.
Jesus Christ, I'm dead.
Jesus Christ.
What?
All right, just gotta dodge him.
He's literally just standing there messingly.
It's like no fucking ride shield and siege where you can't
do shit.
Oh, I don't think he realized it.
I did nothing.
No.
like i'm just
okay like just so i can get this this in oh my god i just
realized that i i can't use my attacks i feel like if i use
it it's just like a waste
holy shit
oh my god i'm
What?
That hits me!
Okay.
All right.
Okay, how the fuck?
Oh my god.
Okay.
Holy shit.
I can't do shit because he's just fucking standing there
There you go Stupid fucking shield
God thank God holy shit I'm just it's just dodge dodge dodge
Yeah, why was he so mad written by?
Virga?
Perhaps that's who this fella has it out for.
Wait, that's not Virga.
Who is he?
Why was he so mad?
Oh my, he did not get stuck.
I felt like I could not, I could not like use any of my
special moves.
It was literally just dodge, dodge, hit, dot.
Wait, what?
What's that over there?
Why is it electrocuting?
Wait, I can select the quest.
Can I?
I don't think so.
It really does not look like it.
Unless it's that.
Or maybe this.
Is it this?
Of course.
Where am I?
Where is this place?
Oh, there you go.
Wait, here?
Oh, feel that?
Where's it coming from?
Down there.
Wait, can I even go down there?
No.
Go down here, though.
Wee.
I will say I'm very lost.
right now.
Ganyar used to live here?
It's just a crater.
It wasn't a crater when they lived here, lad.
Something happened to it.
What?
Like an explosion?
It'd have to be huge.
Oh, there he is.
Oh, hey.
This place has looked better.
He's here too.
Another one of those mysterious crystals.
Hmm?
Say that.
All right, let's go kill these guys.
Okay, where's the healer?
Where the fuck's the healer?
Someone's the healer!
Wait, not you.
You're not getting healed.
Okay, you are getting healed.
Are you getting healed?
Yes, you are.
Oh, it's this!
The fuck is that?
Wait, how the...
All right, there we go.
Oh, shit, wait.
It's fine.
I still have another weapon.
All right, yeah, he can't get healed now.
I got two.
I got five weapons.
My boy is a weapon, too.
He's looking right.
Oh, shit.
Oh, there's another one?
Oh, my God.
Okay, give me a sec, boy.
Boy, I need your help.
Boy, boy, this.
Oh, shit.
All right, I gotta use this, though.
What the fuck?
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck.
Oh my god, I hate this.
I hate this.
Actually, I can't even...
Oh my god, I just need HP.
Okay.
It was actually very annoying.
Oh, shit.
are you fucking oh my god
all right fuck this you win oh my god i don't understand i
can't do anything about it there's not i don't have enough
weapons for this
holy shit this is tempting you don't what do you mean i
don't
Oh my god, it's already lost.
There's no more ice.
There's already no more ice.
I already ran out of ice, guys.
I...
Oh My god That's so oh, I thought I had to kill this guy
again, but it's a new guy
Wait, what the fuck?
Why did they respawn?
I'm gonna say why the fuck did these guys?
What the fuck?
Why are these guys here?
Here we go.
Oh fuck, I thought I timed that.
Yeah.
Oh, I'm going in with no HP though for this.
Oh!
I just feel like I don't have...
Unless, like, I lure her to, like, one area.
I feel like I don't have enough time to kill her.
That was, like, my only worry.
It felt like...
Uh...
You used to live here?
It's just a crater.
It wasn't a crater when they lived here a lot.
Something happened to it.
What?
Like, an explosion?
It has to be huge.
Like, unless I make her be here...
I'll just stay here.
Maybe...
Maybe she'll come to me.
Maybe.
I'm just hoping she'll come to me.
Come over here.
Come on.
Slowly.
Yeah, just slowly.
Almost there.
I mean, sure, I'll kill this guy, I guess.
Oh my god, he walked.
He just walked just enough.
Okay, I just put enough spears on him.
And then he'll walk closer.
Okay, nice.
Are you fucking kidding me?
That hits me?
Okay.
that's fine okay I will do this to cheese this oh my god all
right okay
that's fine
I'm angry now holy shit oh my god I'll take that I'll take
that.
Oh, my God.
I'll take that.
Oh, holy fuck.
I, wait, I cheesed her.
I cheesed the shit out of her.
What's it say, brother?
David, welcome to Tamir Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Holy fuck, that was tilty.
Oh, my God.
Thank God.
oh i swear to god i swear to god if i die to this i swear to
god bad boy you're coming back home to your stepfather
all right give me your shit where exactly do you keep
popping up little one is your boss have you spying on us no
no no no that wasn't our attention you must believe me i am
here solely to serve as a guide but but only if you want all
right nice well you can rest easy we'll get these back to
ratatosa thank you and again sorry if i offended you i i
promise i'll be more helpful next time all right night time
jumpy little fella night time night time
all right let's activate this too
Yeah, but then we don't need anything here.
Oh, all right.
Whoa, what the fuck is this?
What the fuck?
Is the Wisp feeding on it?
We will stop it.
What?
How do we stop it?
Doesn't look like we can kill it.
Maybe we can burn it instead.
Oh, nice.
Going back home to its spring.
Oh, he's still alive?
That's good.
Any healing?
Okay.
If you're sure.
What the fuck?
Anyway.
We should look around.
See if any other wisps have gotten real.
What the fuck?
Whoa!
God fucking damn it.
I'm angry.
Does it regen?
What is that?
Oh, this is so weird.
Hey look, a metal plate with glowy runes.
Think this has anything to do with the wisps?
All right, we'll catch this on fire.
There you go, we saved them.
Two out of three.
Oh, we should do this too.
Oh.
What's that?
You're welcome.
He was nice.
So the boy keeps the wisps lost in their springs.
Except for the ones that broke loose, I guess.
Oh my god.
Okay, how do I do this fast?
I gotta reset this, apparently.
Oh, I have to do this last.
Makes sense.
Okay.
There we go.
Apparently that won't have to be last.
The orders ran longer for some reason.
Oh, nice.
Green apple.
I need one more green apple.
Okay, one more gazelle.
I assume it's that odd.
Yeah, I see you.
I see you on the side.
Don't worry.
All right.
Look, another witch.
Eating that wilderness.
All right, go.
You're free now.
Just a little bird.
A little bird won't hurt nobody.
What?
Nothing?
I was scared.
Oh.
And in pain.
Not anymore.
I was gonna say it's not gonna say thank you.
Better that I had some relief in its final moments That's
all the wisps great the runes are all lit the wisps are back
in their springs and the plates keeping them imprisoned We
did it.
Yeah, what do I get out of it?
Okay, cool.
I guess that's how I get out of it That's cool
There you go.
The dragon's here.
No, come on!
Oh my god, please.
This again!
Oh my god, it's this.
It's that type of...
Oh my god.
Can I get this?
I can't.
God damn it.
Stupid third party.
God damn third party.
Alright.
I think the worst part is that it's so far away.
There you go.
it's all right it's just a boy all right we gotta go to the
next try what the fuck do you okay i was gonna say i was
gonna say oh my god it's so far it's actually so far away
oh my god all right where is he Where is he?
This better be worth it.
This fucking better be worth it.
This...
Like this.
He has no HP.
Where is his HP?
Excuse me?
Where did he go?
God.
Oh my God.
He...
he actually despawned he actually despawned that's so
bullshit
okay here you go
one more or two more wherever the fuck they are are you
fucking kidding me holy shit i don't know where they are oh
my god it's all the way there it's all the way over there.
Holy shit, these guys are so annoying.
Boy, please help out.
Boy!
Oh my god, I'm actually getting fucked up right now.
I'm actually...
I'm just punching.
I'm actually getting so fucked up.
I'm mad
Oh my god, what up?
I'm getting rage baited.
I'm gonna rage bait it so hard
Yeah, I need a fight.
Oh my god, the last shrine is over there It's so fucking
dragon That's all the wisps contained Should we check out
that weird particle?
Great, the runes are all lit.
The wisps are back in their springs and the plates keeping
them in prison using the sphere.
I'm using the sphere.
Why did I not use the sphere in the first place?
Why?
Oh my god.
I'm just gonna use it.
the sphere.
Fuck this.
This fucking stupid third party bullshit.
Does the axe does more overall damage?
I will say.
I think the axe does more overall damage.
The dragon's here!
Alright.
I hate the dragon so much.
I hate Hate the dragon so much!
Holy fuck, the stupid dragon!
Are you fucking...
Okay.
That's fine.
Oh my god, that poison!
I'm so mad right now.
Please.
Oh my god.
I fucked it up.
I'm so, I hate this game.
I hate this boss.
I absolutely hate this boss.
Please.
Are you fucking kidding me?
There you go.
Okay.
Oh my god, those- the dragon.
Where's the next one?
Holy shit.
One more!
I'm gonna get nearer.
Where's the last one?
I don't remember.
It's like here somewhere, right?
Is it this one?
Oh my god, it's this one.
It's this one.
I found it.
Okay.
It's five.
There you go.
Oh my God, you can't do this to me.
Oh my God, thank God.
Two, three, four.
Holy shit, it's over.
It's over.
Oh my god.
Oh!
It's over.
God, fuck the fucking dragon.
Fuck this dragon.
Oh my god, he's still trying to kill me.
The dragon is still trying to kill me right now.
I could see him.
right behind me.
I'm just upgrading everything.
There's no way.
There's no way this dragon is still here.
There is no way!
I just got out of a fight!
What do you mean you still want to fight me?
Oh my god, I'm literally I'm like I just went through a lot
lady Like I don't understand why
I don't understand Where did he go Holy shit!
What the fuck?
Where do I get him?
Wait, what the fuck?
This arrow's not doing shit!
Oh, okay, that's it.
Alright, never mind.
Never mind, I guess.
Oh, now your arrows, that shit, Arteus.
Alright, there we go.
I was gonna say, why is your...
Where'd she go?
Yeah, where did she go?
Huntress is claimed to worship Skadi, but they killed just a
kill.
She would have never wanted that.
No.
Oh.
Even if we do not see it.
All right, where the fuck is Berger?
I thought I need Berger.
Please, please Berger.
Wait over here.
Who?
Speak.
The day this valley was destroyed, my spirit, it was torn,
split in two.
I swear to God the dragon shows up in the middle of my
cutscene.
Perhaps if this brooch was fallen.
It would uncloud my mind.
I could find peace.
What do you remember of the day you died?
Everything is hazy.
I remember I was nervous.
This brooch.
I plan to propose to my beloved.
Please, I beg you, restore me.
Restore my memory.
Then I can tell you, tell you all I know of that day.
your remains where are they i was looking out wait is that
the electric electricity guy in the ground it should is that
him i tried to dodge a pillar as it collapsed i must not
have made it yeah this doctor may be able to tell us what
happened in this valley brother if the leviathan froze that
lightning do you think mother was you know I was a guy that
the it's nothing we do not know that Faye was here not there
but that tells an unfinished story I thought it was you know
like the area where there was a skeleton with electricity
that remembers hmm that is that we go all right guess not
let's try and find burger out wherever he is no doubt about
it just like a frozen lightning bolt and mid god yet i have
never been here curious another side quest something is
wrong with this kill dragons do not leave marks like these
we've seen those marks before in the valender mines remember
must be a soul leader around here i can hear the animals oh
my god hi most people look out for other kills soul leaders
hide in plain sight
I swear to God.
Oh, I thought I can fight that.
Hmm.
I don't know.
It's not really where I have to go.
I'm just going to go straight to the burger.
I don't care anymore.
These other side quests, they can find their own heroes.
I'm going to find burger.
Oh, my oh my god there's another one it's a sign we're on
the right trail we're getting close I remember last time it
looked just like a pile of rocks at first okay I think I
have the unless I can walk around nope nope it's like unless
I can walk around are you fucking kidding me oh my God oh my
God The soul eater!
Okay, um...
Oh, fuck, okay.
Not what I wanted.
Okay, that's, that's so awkward.
That's actually so awkward for me.
Okay.
Um, I'm just gonna figure out what to do here.
Oh my god.
It truly is a party.
You don't have to fuck this.
Fuck this.
I'm just gonna beat...
I'll beat up one of them.
Okay.
I'm doing this!
I can get on top of him!
And then...
I'll use you to fight him!
That's right!
Why are you hitting yourself, huh?
Why are you hitting yourself?
There you go.
There we go.
That's right!
this guy open his
fuck wait wait wait wait wait yes oh my god get him alright
two down last one alright nice alright holy shit I'm sure
Anvari would be happy if he killed alright three down Anvari
the dwarf will put his soul into a Thank God He created the
soul eaters.
Whatever happened to the annoying bugger anyway.
I lent him to sender and he said he lost him Okay, all
right.
It's fine.
It's it's fine.
We we're almost there.
We're almost there
Yeah, that was a lot of XP though next we're we're almost
there guys okay burger should be right around here through
that gate
wish this one were like the dragons and mid they were also
intelligent dwarves who had been transformed into dragons
yeah that's why they were nice because they're finally not
short more.
That, okay, I thought that was Bramble.
Good God, I'm stuck in this eternal side quest.
Oh my God, I'm so tired!
Or is he?
I'm so tired!
What do you mean there's more side?
Ah, quest!
Oh my god, it's these guys, too.
Oh my god, it's these guys again.
But like...
He has no shield this time, at least.
But he just...
It just sucks because he can't get stunned.
Holy fuck.
Get dodged!
Oh fuck.
Oh fuck!
Oh my god, that's not good.
It's okay.
Alright.
What is...
what?
What?!
Okay, how the fuck was I supposed to know that was a weapon?
Okay.
Holy shit, one HP again.
What the fuck was that AoE?
They carried some rice.
Oh, would you?
Seems the travelers were told that by exploring the nine
realms and beyond, they'd find a way into paradise.
Told by whom?
Someone calling themselves the blind guest.
It's just areas just all boss fight.
Doesn't it?
It's just all boss fight.
When will it end?
I heard you like boss fights.
So why don't we put more boss fights?
Bro, I swear to God, I better get some good shit.
Bro, I swear to fucking God, you better give me some good
fucking shit when I get over here.
My savior, goddamn ass.
Oh, no, it's the dragon time.
I, oh, my God.
Oh, my God.
This dragon better get fucking stunned.
I swear to God.
I
swear to God this dragon better get fucking stunned.
I am not fucking around.
I am so done.
Okay.
I didn't realize I was supposed to shoot it.
Oh my god, I'm so done with this dragon.
I am actually so done with him.
Holy shit, I'm so done with you.
I am, I'm so, I, I'm like, I'm dead, but like, I'm so done
with you.
I'm not winning this fight.
I am so fucked right now.
Kick his ass.
Oh, burger.
Guys, I swear to God, if I don't get good shit from this
fight, I swear to God from the side quest of a side quest.
I will be very mad.
Okay, that's unfortunate.
I'm just gonna keep poking him.
All right.
Where is he?
That's fucking right!
It's
supposed to do that situation!
I'm gonna punch you.
Well, you better be doing your fucking shit right now.
How can I make my boy summon the walls?
I'm gonna stab
you.
I'm gonna stab you!
There we go.
Oh my god, get this guy out of here.
Get out of here.
Shoot him, boys.
You're the one thing you're good at.
All right.
There you go.
We did it.
Now we just got to find Birger.
All right, Birger.
Where the fuck are you?
I'm coming for you, Birger.
You might not be dead, but when I'm done with you.
Oh, hey.
Item.
Oh, my God.
The dragon didn't even give me loot.
There's no way.
There's, okay, the glue is all the way there.
Okay, I was gonna say, where the fuck did his loot go?
Okay, so anyway, I saw, how can I activate my son's wolf
powers?
Because he had the triple wolves, but he didn't activate it.
That makes daddy very angry.
I'm very angry that he didn't activate his wolf powers.
Hold his attack button.
Thank you.
Now that I know.
I really needed to know that.
Okay.
Hey, don't mind me.
Someone in the chat needs to hear this.
Oh, okay.
Thank you for the super chat binary.
Thank you.
All right.
All right, Burger.
When I'm done with you, you wish you were dead.
I fought like 20 bosses in this one area alone.
Bro's trying to activate a sleeper agent.
Oh my god, there you are.
Many thanks.
No, thank you.
You saved us back on the boat.
Right, father?
It was foolish.
And appreciated.
There's a mystic gateway nearby.
But I have no stone for it.
It's okay.
I do.
I can't believe.
let's go home how'd you do it there's a deer here a little
magical deer boss needs your help coaxing this stag back to
the world tree the boss needs your help mind you not me i'm
doing great got a belly full of stag feed living life but i
like how the squirrel the squirrel interrupted um the
squirrel interrupted burgers laura i did so much how do i
take him back home speak to, oh, okay.
The, I worked so hard spent, like, at least an hour to grab
this guy, and then the squirrel fucking interrupts the lore
of how he survived the fall, and I'll never know how.
I'll I'll never know how he survived the fall.
he rolled he just rolled oh my god i have no need for this
maybe i'll see you back he parried the ground under
different circumstances one hopes
i was like oh magical deer and then i'll never know i'm
going home fuck this area i killed the dragon i saved burger
i'm going home We can get out of here.
I want to explore some more.
No.
Wait, what item did I grab?
I got a shield.
This is a better shield.
Oh, yeah.
This is a lot better shield.
Holy shit.
Alright, we go home.
We still need to unlock Yoderheim and Asgard.
What the fuck?
No, we're going home.
I do not want to do any of these quests.
I
wanted to tell you I read something in Odin's library about
what Gallowon is supposed to do yeah what about the frozen
health that would be the mystery of a lifetime that always
remain a mystery the realm travel towers at once it's quite
a vulnerability wonder why he didn't just destroy it some
artifacts defy destruction well we should make Freya aware
of this All right, I'm gonna eat my mochi donut.
Hmm.
Nice.
All right.
Okay.
Master Kratos!
Thank you for coming.
Much to discuss.
Wise beyond its years, this one.
it in its eyes speak the tree has become rather overgrown
and and if it grows too wildly the branches risk getting too
heavy and it's like donuts but they're like softer the donut
itself it's really good what an absolute mochi donuts are so
good require any horticultural skills from you but i would
ask that you keep an eye open for the stags of the four
seasons they normally graze Unfortunately, Pitter decided it
would be funny to trick arrogant into releasing them.
If you happen to find the stags during your travels, I would
greatly appreciate assistance in bringing them home.
I guess the tree is gonna keep on growing.
Keep eating the feed I give them.
Consequence of it being the most delicious food in all the
nine realms, I suppose.
We have seen these stags.
I personally like mochi donuts more than regular donuts.
Once you found a stag, the feed should calm them down.
Then one of my spectrals will guide them back here.
And, uh, don't eat the feed, please.
I will not.
Vigenus asked me if I was too chicken to release them, but I
am in fact not a chicken like whatsoever.
I'm going to use the bathroom.
I'll be right back, guys.
Yes, of course.
What else could you have done?
While normally this would be a harmless prank, Fimblewinter
prevented the stags from returning.
And now they have long since scattered to parts unknown.
It was worth it.
them any luck finding those lean worms
i am back it's time it's time to go back home my home
hello everybody you have always been the best hey tell her
she's the best oh is he drunk the heroes of the hour why is
he drunk here everything i mean when you're ready oh burgers
are not by the way am i try to rest envy oh he's high okay
yeah i was gonna say is he drunk or oh my god wait he's
drunk and high it's a term for that i forgot you make the
word you always have since since we were kids i find a new
way to get into trouble and you find a way cross baited yeah
well that's certainly true oops sorry i'm trying to put my
advice away you know we used to lead vanaheim sd they give
the five give the ships they get thank you oh my god oops i
pressed the escape button again not much older than you to
be honest well she did the leading i just tried to keep
things fine leadership my strong suit let's be honest really
your group back in Vanaheim seems pretty devoted well yeah
but what happened to the rest of his art rebellion people I
guess and get them to see the best in themselves you know I
don't know if that's leadership did more like like a muse
wait like a what like a what muse father told me about them
in his homeland they inspired all kinds of artists what I
love that that's a job yeah they're all the Greeks man I
think all the cool shit that's not fair that's not fair I I
would be a natural oh what were we talking about oh yeah no
he's out of it you must rest you understand you must please
like all i got to do is just sit there and be pretty god why
was i playing with someone for a noise was gonna fill us in
on what happened with heimdall right is that what's
happening
want to say love what the riddle what gets big oh we're
still here oh we're still on this buffling relationships
you've been in them here and don't make any sense agreed oh
fun i won't be lectured on the nature of a romance by the
two of you duffers yes bigger the more you take away i know
hey what about no i said rest what about what though hey you
think enough
look at that uh-huh you really did it how in all the nine
realms did you manage to kill heimdall i knew our spear
would do the trick well happy ragner rock everybody yay It's
the end of the world.
Let's celebrate.
I'm Doll's dead.
I can't believe it.
There's no stopping it now.
Odin swore peace only so long as you spilled no more Asir
blood.
I refuse that deal.
Yet he honored it.
Merry Christmas.
But what?
You and I know better than anyone that Odin's promises never
last.
We have the advantage now.
It's time to bring him down.
None of you understand what's coming.
Odin's vengeance will be his only concern.
Not his only concern.
I don't want a pussy.
He never wants to do anything fun.
That's what Odin wants more than anything.
If I go back to Asgard, I can't use...
Back.
Look.
If I can finish what I started there, awaken the mask, get
answers.
Maybe that's our way out of this.
But I gotta go soon.
Before they figure out what's happened.
Andreas, you are home.
Do not ask me to put you at risk again.
He's at risk where he stands, Kratos.
We all are.
Anything we do or don't do is dangerous right now.
But Odin needs me.
He trusts me.
I'll be safe there.
From a tactical perspective, am I wrong?
I don't much like it, but it is our best play.
Dividing Odin's focus would buy us time.
And give us a pair of eyes in the enemy's inner sanctum.
But if there is truly a source of infinite knowledge, Yeah,
I was going to say, what if, like, I am helping Odin.
Then I lose my leverage.
I was going to say, like, why, if you help Odin, he ends up
unlocking the mask.
And he gets it, then he'll have the advantage.
I can do this.
Wouldn't it be better just not do the mask thing?
Just let him, like, continue.
Because that's all he wants.
He just wants infinite knowledge from the mask.
And if we don't give him what he needs, then he'll never get
it.
I do too, son.
And his plan is fucking stupid.
He'll never, if he never continues, if he never helps with
the match thing, Odin will never have it.
That's all he's obsessed with.
Hunter, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
There's certain side quests you do at the end of the game.
When you finish the game, tell me.
Or you could...
Well, how am I going to tell you if you're just going to
leave?
I feel like you will know when I finish the game.
Like, how can I send a signal to the sky?
Like, Toki has finished the game.
Just tell her.
Dude, you look super chatty.
When you look up in the sky, you will know she has finished
the game.
I can't let you go back without this.
A hammer?
Your key, please.
Someone light the bad signal.
All this just to become Jimmy Gary from the mask.
And see, uh, NSD, thank you for chatting.
Thank you.
One use only.
Weirge.
Okay.
Thanks, Injury.
Hope I don't need it.
Me too.
I need a fireman in a side quest to tell him.
I was gonna say, wait, I feel like you would know when I
finished the game, though, wouldn't you?
All right.
Odin said Hogan would be waiting in the cabin.
Mimir, anything else I should know about Odin?
Maybe a weakness or something.
Like if I flip up his eye patch, he'll disintegrate.
All right, Lord.
Wouldn't I be?
Yeah, no.
Sorry, Mimir.
I can't do your accent.
I'm on my own for this one.
Yeah, my magic door.
here we go here we go again i'm home and then from home i
get to go to my other home odin gets me on the weekends
oh what the fuck oh is that my giant dog my giant dog oh my
god bro he's got mark his territory get in the house What
the fuck?
Oh, shit.
My first girlfriend.
Oh, were you having a moment?
It sort of looked like you were having a moment.
I can go.
No.
Sorry.
This is Fenrir.
Oh, he brought a stick.
You wanted to play fetch.
So cute.
He's so cute.
So I was right about your knife.
I'm glad you found a place for us.
Oh, my God.
We were like one door away from my first girlfriend.
my second girlfriend.
How'd you find me here?
Loki?
Oh, that's my...
Oh, that's my ball!
My marble!
And where are you heading off to?
Back to Asgard.
Hey, I'm actually using him.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
Oh, no.
It's the women's judging looks.
The women...
Uh-huh.
You know the one.
how to save my father how to stop Ragnarok where she goes
uh-huh I bring our people back Loki those are all very noble
intentions but he's Odin you have faith in me right of
course I do I just hope this story you're writing for
yourself is the one that you truly want would you would you
take care of fan while i'm away oh that's sweet oh
my god we should show like his brother and sister like look
be careful loki the other brother's back how is he gonna eat
like what the fuck are gonna feed him.
We did not think this through.
Yeah, how much does Vinny?
Okay.
We can feed him bear.
Guys, I don't think there's enough bears in this forest to
feed him every day.
But also make sure he doesn't get any answers from it.
Easy, right?
He's probably in a study.
Is there anything in here?
Nicely equipped.
What needs work?
I still like this bow.
Yeah, I was gonna say a couple of animals are definitely
gonna go in extinct with this giant dog around.
Hmm.
Nicely equipped.
What needs work?
I can upgrade these.
I might as well do it.
I have so many, but I just can't be bothered.
But is he still an undead wolf or is he now living wolf
because we put a soul in him?
He was undead and soulless because he didn't have a soul.
But shouldn't he be like a real wolf now?
But just giant?
Just because someone isn't here to defend themselves doesn't
mean they're guilty.
Baby, thank you for the raid.
I hope you had a great stream.
We can feed him the troll bosses from the first game.
I need a super chat crow so they can thank you.
He's still undead?
Oh, shit.
Yay!
Okay, we don't have to feed him anymore.
That's good.
We don't have to feed our wolf.
Hello, second girlfriend.
Can I come inside with you?
You think she's still angry at me?
I think she's still angry with me.
All right, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Probably.
Okay, panic does nothing.
Harness it.
Heimdall's dead.
Happened to know something about that.
Anything?
How did you find out?
i guess because he didn't come back sure sure but have you
seen anything something noteworthy i mean you know he did
sock through pretty hard while we were out maybe someone
found out he's dead who could have done it are you
suggesting my son had something to do with this i don't know
honest Well, I had to ask.
Never believed you had anything to do with this.
I'm glad you're back.
So, I figured out what went wrong.
I mistranslated a word here.
Did you know?
I thought it said beyond the cry of cold breath, but it
actually reads the cry of first breath.
Well, that's somewhere else entirely.
I know where that is.
young man you've done it again go take the mask take the
sword take the bird a bird find Thor oh the crows we're
going to Nifilheim Nifilheim we're back to the elves well I
guess like he did not care the Haimdell died it was like
Haimdell's dead anyway Ingrid you wouldn't happen to know
where Thor is yeah anyway we're gonna talk about the mask
now uh hi sif know where your husband is you know where i
can find thor all father is sending us on another mission oh
it's the ice place okay where to find anyone i cared about
look oh it's fine if you don't like me or trust me or
whatever but i want you to know that you're hurting her
excuse me through it's going to be a valkyrie one way or
another you know that if you don't stand with her you're
gonna lose her you may be working with all father and
enjoying his little bubble of protection but stay out of my
family you don't tell me how to raise my daughter enjoy your
freedom while you still have it damn right all right how do
I hello oh wait where did second girlfriend go maybe I
should stop by my room It might be a while before I can fix
up my equipment again.
Okay.
I mean, can I upgrade my sword?
I was going to say I already upgraded everything.
What else do I need to upgrade?
Hmm.
Nicely equipped.
What needs work?
Yeah, I was going to say, nothing needs work right now.
Should be properly geared.
Alright, let's go.
How do I go there?
Do I not need to go down?
downstairs oh you want to come down with me um all father
said i'm supposed to head to nephelheim with your dad i
haven't seen him around and i was wondering if you had any
idea where he could be he wasn't with grandfather no i think
i know where he might be follow me what the fuck you didn't
finish your apple also want your apple don't don't you're
right later that was a perfectly
More angry upgrade.
More angry, Juice.
Oh, fuck.
Light mode.
Back in Helheim.
I told you I'd help your mom understand how much becoming a
Valkyrie meant to you.
I wanted to let you know that I meant it.
You didn't.
And you're still alive?
I did think she was gonna choke me with her hair.
I'm honestly surprised she didn't.
Thanks, Lucky.
Yay!
She forgave me!
I'm still in.
Weapons aren't allowed inside.
We'll have to check them.
Why?
Blank Black Thunder.
Oh.
They're not gonna let you in otherwise.
Oh, but he's holding all the weapons.
I don't trust him.
Look around.
He'll be here.
Oh, he's like a little tavern.
Oh.
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Seems like it might be a bad time, so...
If you need a moment, I totally understand.
No rush, but...
Right where I thought you'd be.
Yeah, you shouldn't be here.
You...
You shouldn't have brought her here.
Why?
He's like, No, don't look at me!
He's like, he's like, don't look at me.
I meant we should keep going, right?
We don't want to keep the all.
Oh, yeah, she's, yeah, she's not supposed to enter the bar.
She's underage.
Oh, that's so depressing.
But I didn't want her to see me like this.
Don't do this.
It's already done.
Huh?
What?
Let it be known, the god of thunder is good for two things.
Killing giants and pissing mead.
Any man who disagrees will greet you.
He's hit rock bottom.
With his face.
Oh man, this is sad.
She has to look at her father hit rock.
bottom this isn't you Thor mm-hmm Hugen is waiting outside
please let's just I said quiet wait how come he gets to have
his weapon my name is oh shit oh no it's bar fight time oh
no no I oh come on no no I swear that really wasn't
Oh, fuck, he's gonna turn into a bear!
Don't make him angry!
He's gonna let the beast out!
Hey, that's cheating.
That's a weapon.
Use your fist like a man, boy!
Oh, and he's still got it!
Oh, shit.
Yeah!
Fight, fight, fight, fight, fight, fight, wait, not me.
Wait a minute.
Wait.
I didn't mean me.
I just wanted to watch.
I'm getting our weapon.
Is my sword gonna help?
He's just watching.
Oh, shit.
I know you can help
All right, all right, thank you guys still have my bow It's
Ingrid's time to watch All right, nice All right, he's down.
Okay, what?
The help is like right there Don't you think?
Oh
Brariness for drinking.
Not thinking.
All right, nice.
You carried.
Okay, nice.
I'll grab HP real quick.
Oh, fuck.
Oh.
I'd rather take forever to kill.
Alright, nice.
HP.
Alright, off we go.
More?
Oh, shit.
I think I'm in love.
That's right, stop hitting yourself.
It's alright.
We can resurrect you.
You're already dead anyway.
Don't worry, I'll say you to Bahala!
Myself!
Oh, fuck.
I was wondering, are they like, if you die by a little boy,
do you still get sent to Vahala or are you sent to like, or
they're like, no, that's a pussy way to die.
I'm actually curious.
They're be like, sorry.
You died by a 13 year old boy.
You can't let you into Vahala.
Is it?
Will Odin be mad I'm killing Inrior?
They're already dead.
They can't really die yet.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
Are they already dead?
So it doesn't matter.
Oh my god, Muir and Ingrid are fighting right now.
Oh my god.
Forbidden love!
A sword and a hammer!
The 13-year-old, uh, warrior.
When a hammer and a sword love each other very much, they
start touching tips.
Wait, but the hammer doesn't have a tip.
The hammer touches the tip of the sword.
What if you started again?
Oh, wait.
Was he 18 years sober?
And then, oh, no.
Let's get him out of here.
No, he has to turn to, he has to turn in his sobriety chip.
I'm sorry you had to see him like this.
No, no.
It's fine.
It's okay.
It's alright.
You know, I gotta look, I gotta get to know my
father-in-law.
Better.
But I take him back to rehab, though.
Oh, no.
He relapsed.
I don't know.
It feels like I just only walked, like, 25 center meters.
Also, Maxi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I love how much you engage in the forbidden love shipping.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, God.
The light!
My eyes!
Thor?
Get up.
You are going to Nephalheim with Loki.
All father's orders.
You have to get up.
I know you're disappointed.
I'm pretty sure he's been there for like a couple months
already.
No, no, no.
That was a glorious fight.
No, she's got to let mom deal with this.
You're sorry this time, can you?
Oh.
So that's one more broken bonus.
He's a bad, he's a deadbeat.
He only has one daughter left.
You were struggling.
I get it.
But you can't just...
You can't just continue the cycle, man.
with you
we're here for you mom and I oh even when you were here we
love you you know that cronies therapy for real I just
thought this was behind us I fucked up oh yeah you fucked I
can't even look at her.
I know.
He's crying now.
He knew his daughter.
Oh, fuck.
What the?
His daughter doesn't respect him anymore.
You know what or something?
Even God.
need therapy guys if anything they need more therapy let's
make this quick you in a hurry to get back to asgard just
get us to that mask piece where do i go this way all right
it's this way i remember this place oh i haven't been here
in so long especially guys
Okay.
I don't remember how to...
Well, this isn't the way.
I remember how to play as Arctreus.
It's been a while.
This part of Nephilim is way different than the maze I saw a
few winters ago.
If you came through Tears Temple, then yeah.
The mist around Evaldi's workshop.
Was it worth it?
I don't know what you're talking about.
Fine, but I hope you know what's seeing you like that hit
me.
I was drunk not blind Oh my god took so long to kill him
It's time for me to whack him with my fucking go Yeah It's
this way that means I go this way Yeah Reload.
This way.
Follow me, Thor.
Yeah, honestly.
I'm 13!
You won't even feel anything!
What do you mean?
I'm pretty sure I'm not that heavy, Thor.
I was like, what the fuck I...
Alright.
Everybody looks up to you.
I hope you know that.
Don't need a lecture about parenting from you.
You just find the thing.
Alright.
Must be here.
We gotta head through that wall.
You wanna...
Go or smash!
What?
Oh.
Oh, okay.
Oh, all right.
Thank God your daughter's not here to see this.
No.
I thought I was going to pee.
I was going to sit.
I was like, you call me fat?
You really keep trying.
90% of this is my armor.
Right.
Have giant son of a powerful god with impossibly high
expectations.
How could I ever know what that's like?
all right it's a very unique experience i've never heard
before
you can you help me he's still alive is he gonna smash him
yeah yeah totally unrelated never heard of that before very
unique experience what the fuck there fuck yeah i'm setting
out the woods
oh god damn all right nice that's right do a backslip i'm
not trying to do anything i'm just pointing out we're not
that different
I should be another wall of ice this way Thor could you all
right do your thing Thor smashy smashy okay I just want to
add one more thing if you can't be yourself you also might
not feel like you can follow your own path that doesn't
sound familiar to you at all Yeah.
I'll give you this guy.
I'll give that to you.
Oh, Star, come on!
What the fuck?
I gave you one job, bro.
How did he fucking walk past you?
That's insane.
that he literally just walked past him.
Nice.
I feel like he's smashing it with my bow.
That's more damage.
Toki, he's drunk.
He might be fighting the second guy.
he's like seeing two doubles and he's like don't worry i got
the second one i was like what second one so we've got some
similar life experience what does it matter seems stupid to
gripe about the things we can't change who says we can't
all right i have so much money right now
Oh my god.
Fuck this.
Oh, nice.
Oh, that did a lot.
That did a lot of damage.
That's a lot of damage.
Okay, nice.
There's more?
Okay, that's fine.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Get the walls out!
oh
all right there you go jesus that guy has so much hp
we're far from evaldi's workshop right far enough okay that
means we go here we're the one loot
I don't think I did anything.
Apparently, fighting the legs did not work, guys.
Who would have thought?
Thor, can I?
Thor, please.
He's just looking at me menacingly.
Thor, Thor, please.
Thor, please.
Okay.
But that's it.
Thor, please!
I need a bigger child.
What do you mean?
Is that not big enough?
oh my god all i do is just kicking it there we go there we
go that's what he needs a giant love hell walkers you just
blast them apart poof problem solved don't have to think
don't have to feel just fight okay this way This way?
This way.
Through there.
Or do your thing.
Do your thing, big bro.
Go grab this heal.
I don't think that's where we're supposed to go.
Oh, okay.
That's cool.
Just wants to keep on fighting.
He's creating his own Valhalla.
What's over here?
I fucking knew it.
Alright, back up.
What do you want to say when you see them again?
Siff and Throod, I mean.
If all father is pleased, it doesn't matter.
Look, I don't need you to solve my family problem.
It doesn't need you to be a therapist.
Let's get out of here.
He can handle this himself like a man.
Oh, do your thing.
Not do your thing?
What?
Oh, it's this way?
What the fuck?
Yeah, he broke the wrong wall.
So I was like, oh.
Is there, like, another area to go to?
Why can't you just break the right wall?
Looks like there's a path.
Oh, I have to ask him to break it again.
Okay.
One pathway coming up.
You're enjoying the freedom.
I, uh, well, yeah i guess it's different from what i'm used
to in a good way
looks like we got to get up that cliff which i think no
thinking oh so now you're okay with caring me it's better
when i know what's gonna happen
oh my god i think we're bonding guys guys i think i think
we're bonding do you get thank you let's reach out thank you
thank you i know i'm a bit late since i couldn't catch a
stream earlier but happy new year here's my small red
envelope i wish the best of luck at prosperity in the coming
thank you thank you so much for the super chat i can check i
hope you also had a good lunar new year as well appreciate
you just dropping by
okay easy easy
look we're trauma bonding What is this?
Nothing?
Hello?
Oh, are we supposed to go here?
I thought, like...
Oh, okay, nothing.
It was actually nothing.
Oh, is that for Kratos?
Oh, Kratos is going to be back here.
Okay.
Yeah, I was going to say, is that not the...
I guess Kratos will be back there.
Okay.
yeah that makes sense i was like wondering why i can't
interact with it because i thought i could like solo it you
know it's fine he barely does any damage
oh nice i was hoping for thor to finish that so i can loot
the item okay
We go this way.
Thor, I, um, hope everything goes okay when you see Siffin
through it again.
Well, hoping it's better than you're thinking.
It's a start.
Alright.
Oh, nice.
Oh, goodbye.
Get out of here!
Slam dunk!
There we go.
Oh, he has some stuff.
Thinking bad.
Just...
Just go with pure instinct.
Listen to your heart.
What?
Oh, there.
Oh, it's this guy.
It's right here.
It's here.
Oh!
He's calling
for me.
Phew.
That was close.
Um, thanks, Thor.
Wasn't about to lose that guy.
I was going to say, I think he just wanted to...
He wanted to make sure the mask is safe.
All of our work together.
You're welcome.
Yeah, what about Thor, huh?
I'm sorry.
You are here.
Why?
His father murdered Heimdall.
Fersetti has proof.
Take him.
No.
Leave him alone.
I command it.
You said no more Asir blood would be spilled.
You said family comes first.
You don't think that this is retribution for him being here?
He's put your granddaughter in danger.
He's made your son miserable.
Loki didn't kill Heimdall.
His father did.
Your daughter is old enough to make her own mistakes.
And your husband started drinking again all on his own.
Dismissed!
You two.
The cycle continues.
Can't you see what's happening?
He's not protecting us.
You have to take power.
For me.
We used to tell them stories by the fire.
Do you remember?
Aww.
We would carve those wooden horses.
play and laugh and now you only have one daughter they were
thrown at the all-father's problems like brittle knives to a
mountain face and for what what if fruit's next
holy his hands are the size of her face oh my god i'm sorry
i just realize the size difference between the two.
You kill my son.
Okay, why is he mad at him?
In their beds.
Turn my father against me.
Like, I think she was talking about...
I have no idea what's happening.
I know.
I finally thought of something.
I can teach you.
Hey, you're here.
Century better be right.
Oh, shit.
Oh,
he's got the mask.
No!
Ingrid!
Yeah,
but then the sword...
But then that means the sword is gonna get punished.
Wait, why were you out here?
Sentry told us where you would arrive should you find
trouble.
Oh my god, he was just waiting for him.
I thought you might have been exploring without me.
Oh, he's gonna be so pissed.
So, now that you mention it...
Lameer.
Brother, please, it's all so crowded and tense back home.
don't you miss the three of us out finding our own
adventures putting off the inevitable exactly i thought me
and thor were finally bonding i do want to show i'm in the
woman the woman ruined it got in the way they always ruined
the bro relationships it's like when your bro finally gets a
girlfriend and now there's no more late night gaming because
has to be like sorry bro i gotta get in a discord call with
my girl all right
pro time is over uh yeah i was gonna say didn't like sif was
like talking about like trying to like to be like you gotta
be a man you gotta fight back to odin and then flora's like
you're right i gotta kill the
like, wait a minute, why me?
I thought we were on the same page here.
Flutter.
They give us super chat.
They can thank it because that's what heroes do.
Bricks our train.
This is neck.
Then give us a super chat.
Yeah, he's like, you're right.
I shall kill the child.
Maxi saw.
Yeah, he was like, he definitely got the wrong message.
be a horrible father and how he shouldn't listen but thor
couldn't have that kind of confrontation and deflected on
chase a lot of people miss yeah i was gonna say i was like i
thought we were on the same page here why the fuck did you
go after the boy he's like you coward also i need to get
water i'll be right back
i'm back uh whoa whoa whoa whoa neppers gas jail four nexy
papa john Medi, solid.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Patreso, the devs never miss an opportunity to visit
deep-sea trauma about their dads and put it on Odin or Thor
creatives.
I swear.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
It's called Daddy Issues, the game.
But I got the mask.
I did it, guys.
I'm back, everybody.
You made it.
I'll get to here.
Do you want to set the table if you're ready to stay?
I told you the key would get him home Because you tapped it
with a hammer Dwarven magic makes no sense Right?
Luna one time Made me a breastplate out of dog barks You're
back I still can't figure out What the fuck?
I'm fine I just hope unlocking this thing was worth the cost
You have it What did it show you?
I didn't get to use it They found out about Heimdall I had
to run But at least Odin can't use it either But if you
didn't get any answers from the mask all you've done is
steal Odin's greatest treasure so just after your father's
killed his most loyal ally none of us are safe even here so
we have no choice we find Serder sound Galehorn and bring
Odin to justice now you'd incinerate every soul in Asgard
and call itself defense you see I had shut the fuck up here
is it we don't need odin to use this we can slip into asgard
and do it ourselves right under his nose we gain the
knowledge we need to shatter this prophecy of war once and
for all god i hate him such a hippie oh so you expect them
to sneak into asgard blowing a horn that sounds across all
the I expect you to bite my blue butt.
Please.
Just think about it.
This guy.
Why are we even listening considered here's plan?
His plans fucking suck.
Bro.
He's the god of pacifists, not the god of war no more.
What do you think?
this mask the easy answers that it promises i know this
shortcuts always have a price atreus you have carried it at
least he has a plan i'm thinking we'll have something odin
wants his leverage at best he didn't give me a time he
didn't give me prep time nobody has to die grand now we need
the way to asgard
I know I've been a burden to you all I know you've
questioned why you even pulled me out of that hole I have to
but it's clear now this is what I'm needed for is he
fighting a man up this is my purpose one last time I will
pick up my spear and I will lead us to ask Oh, well, now
you'll lead us to Asgard.
Excuse me, but if you got a way to Asgard, where's that idea
been this whole fucking while?
What?
Not that I fear question, brother.
That is true.
Who's held Asgard?
You would have gotten us all killed.
That is true.
We could have had that info earlier.
It's all led to this.
If we can get inside, after Odin.
They will not stop you.
We can do both.
Spot on, brother.
If the mask doesn't give us an out, we'll still have the
drop on him.
Works for me.
Let's do it then, and quickly, before he sees us coming.
He does hate surprises.
Slow down, you damn spruce.
I still want to hear the details on this, uh, new way to
Asgard you got.
Spill it!
It's an ancient We can't reach it from here.
Where then?
Let me collect my things and I'll show you.
You ain't got no things.
And where are you going with that mask?
Brock!
That belongs to the kid.
He earned it.
All you've done was make passable dirt suit.
Brock, it's okay.
No, it ain't.
This ain't right.
All the pieces ain't welding together, true.
Like, what's with him calling you Loki anyway?
You know that ain't his name.
Hey, I'm talking to you.
You never shut up.
Brock!
All the things.
What?
Let go of the boy and face me.
Tell your brother to throw me the mask and you've got a
deal.
Stop moving.
Freya, if he dies, what?
No, no.
It wasn't part of the plan, but if he dies, we are square
for Heimdall.
And honestly, You got a bargain.
I will kill you.
Plan on that.
Mm-hmm.
So nice spending time with you again.
Freya, please.
Uh-uh-uh-uh.
Can't be in two places at once, Frigg.
Hey!
I don't move.
You don't move.
Don't do anything to regret.
I regret many things.
Killing you will not be one of them.
Unless what's up.
I am in control.
Here.
Throw me the mask.
Now.
I don't
do it.
No!
Oh!
Too bad, son.
Looks like war after all.
We still got the mask.
Is he okay?
Please, you have to save him.
You have to.
What did we just find the one more soul you can't no maybe
if i go back to the lake yeah that's what i'm saying what if
we go back to the lake and grab this last soul i know what
you've done and i forget you
you gotta stop let him die he gotta let go
will he turn like red if we revive him one more time oh does
he change colors or will he still be blue so don't keep
please he just died now now
Now we kill you made credos list now.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What?
Where?
It does not matter.
You live the smurf.
He died.
A smurf.
Papa, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You mean then what happened?
to tear like he was tear the entire time no wonder it was
such a fucking pussy i i want to know is tears voice actor
the same as um the same as odin until we stop him we need
you here
but like the prophecy said tear was gonna be there the
prophecy lied
Not the same voice actor.
Okay, he had like, I was going to say, they sounded very
similar at first.
Father, where are we going?
Oh.
About all parts of the soul.
He won't have an afterlife.
Okay, you got to find a fourth soul.
We don't bring him back, but at least like let him have an
afterlife.
They use the Super Chat.
They can thank him.
Maxie, they use the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Madame, thank you.
Super chat, thank you.
Thank you.
A big tease about Odin being tears that whenever he's
talking, his name doesn't have the accent over the Y.
Real tear is still missing.
Thank you, the Super chat, thank you.
Thank you.
Alan, thank you, the Super chat, thank you, thank you.
The God of War will lead the Battle of Ragnarok.
They never said which God of War.
Yeah, but like, his face was on the prophecy.
That's why I was so confused.
We saw his face in the, like, in the...
in the sand raider thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you i thought that was him
father can we i i want to go hunting what the fuck bro it's
the end of the okay whatever let's go hunting whatever it's
the end of the world Oh, it was a helmet.
He was so tall.
Oh, it was me.
I'm also tall.
All right.
Let us...
What's the word?
Let us disassociate and hunt.
It's our coping mechanism.
He needs stress relief.
Let's avoid our all-responsive.
responsibilities.
It's time to cope.
Yeah, avoiding responsibilities.
Let's go.
It's the end of the world.
Do you wish to speak of what happened?
No wonder he was such a fucking pussy.
I was like, there's no way this is the god of war.
I knew there was a reason why I hated him.
Yeah.
Are being weak as hell.
That's why he was always, like, two steps ahead of us.
He was the inside man.
Violence changes us.
You are not weak to feel its effects.
We're all feeling its effects.
We're heading the right way.
There's broken branches over there.
Come on.
I keep...
seeing it the night Brock centuries face son there it is
yeah he knows all our plans there's
a spy on the blue base
elbow up accuracy over speed
like what Oh my god, I had to.
Why?
And that was running.
And so are we.
Huh?
I don't understand.
When an animal is wounded, it must stop the bleeding, or it
will die.
We have been wounded.
And this...
This is a distraction.
It's my fault.
No.
Brock hated tear from the start.
I hated tear from the start.
We're the same.
We should find Sindri.
I all, too, have three out of four souls.
I have a pretty good idea where he might be.
Chad, I'm thinking of the super Thank you.
Thank you.
The nature of a thing is more important than a form of
thing.
Brock discerned Odin's nature despite his form being tear.
Brock was the goat.
Thank you for the screenshot.
Thank you.
I was too was a day one hated.
Is it okay if we take the sleds?
I knew it.
When people started like- When people started accepting him,
I was like, no!
I don't like it.
everywhere i look i'm reminded of my now a reason to
actually hate him you know like those people were like i
never had a reason to be a hater but now i do this teacher
like i knew there was something bad about him but now i can
hate him with reason seen through a deception that fooled us
all stopped an attack you could not predict there is no if
atreus your father's right of soy that's good vindication
huh oh are you okay wines lovingly okay they're
okay i'm not supposed to go oh the sled come come wait why
would a retired sled on the big dog Then, like, he could
take us there in one second.
When the content creator you hated for being annoying,
finally does something genuinely awful.
True!
I love those moments.
You're like, finally, I am justified.
Alright, so thank you for the super shot.
Thank you, thank you.
The flashbang I warned about is in the end.
It goes for, like, two minutes, but pair of your sunglasses.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Here's simple.
That's where we're headed.
Gun vault.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
Mimir, is there a chance that we could bring Brock back?
Sentry did it once.
Maybe we could figure out a way to do it again.
I'm afraid not, little brother.
When a soul missing its full year, It's direction like
brocks leaves its corporeal form Well, it can't reach the
lake of souls He's not only dead.
He's been denied an afterlife.
We can nothing to bring back.
Oh It's really gone wait, but there's still one more soul in
the lake We could just be one out of four souls.
He might not be fully there But we can still bring him.
Oh man, what imagine like what we will get if we just give
him one of that soul one out of four yeah but like there's
still one more in the lake though the water I feel like I
want to get on a boat and just sail away from here from
everything you cannot sail away from their mistakes it is
impossible to forget them I have tried I will follow you
that sounds really bad like we zombie brock do it towards
somewhere
the lift at the end of the bridge it's coffee bird thank you
the super chat burrito thank you thank you there's still a
wave it'll just be one out of four
let him rest he's not even resting he doesn't even have an
afterlife
holy shit this place is far Atreus what makes you so sure
Sindri will be here?
It's where he and Brock reunite.
Oh are you forging something that broke?
Oh.
That means when Sindri passes away he won't even get to meet
Brock in the afterlife.
Oh that's so sad.
That's actually so sad.
Even when he passes away he'll never get to meet his
brother.
We'll never get to see his brother again.
Sindri, I...
I'm so sorry.
No.
No, I don't want to hear it.
You don't know what sorry means.
Hmm.
We're not letting Odin get away with this.
Who would that be the Odin you invited into my home?
Hmm.
We were all fooled.
Oh.
But some of us were bigger fools than others.
Aren't we?
I gave you everything.
Oh.
My skills.
My friendship.
My home.
My secrets.
Oh.
And you just kept taking.
And taking.
And now what have I got?
The dead brother.
there you want sorry this is what sorry looks like i what
can we do we there is no way there's only falling apart no
matter what the cost so what you can do everything's falling
apart the fuck out of my sight.
Come, Atreus.
Leave it be.
More than how you wish.
He lost everything.
I thought we were his family, too.
Oh.
So, like, and I...
Can you upgrade my sword?
Like, I wasn't involved.
You're mad at my son?
Not me, though.
Oh no, guys.
No more.
No more upgrades.
There's no making this right.
Who is there?
No more upgrades.
He's mad at my son, not me!
Justice is not what we seek.
It is vengeance.
Every path I walk leads back to vengeance.
Maybe that's all we have left.
Vengeance.
We must return to Freya.
Oh no, he kicked me off the family plan, guys.
We're...
We really are going to war.
He just come to that.
Just as the prophecy foretold.
When we were back in Svartalfan, looking for Tyr.
This isn't what I wanted.
Bro, kicked me off the Netflix account.
He changed his password.
We know Atreus.
we know it's like you know he could take that anger it makes
me we really took everything from Sindri don't take to heart
words said in grief Atreus no matter how spot on they feel I
know we should go see Freya but I wouldn't mind staying here
in Midgard for a little while I have a few last adventures
to take our minds off the well everything um that looks an
awful lot like a raider can't to me shall we take care of
them brother um i feel like we should as his brother said
joking all i care about us i'm crazy who deserved this start
thinking this super chat thinking yes but he could upgrade
my stuff as like revenge for odin you know make me better
gear make me better gear for his revenge against odin
is it where do i go like here is that not the case yeah he
can hate forage
what it could be like if you want your revenge we can do it
now
all right all
right I hear you.
We'll still be at the house.
Don't see why not.
Odin's back door in was also his way out.
Holy shit.
10,000?
Finally hiding.
Oh my god.
Sorry.
That need to upgrade.
Oh my god.
10,000.
Nice.
The room closet.
The house should be secure.
I'm rich.
She will not turn away allies in her vengeance.
Aye.
It's all our vengeance now.
I'm no more fake tier to twist our minds of us.
Brock made me dead.
But I got 10k XP.
Blades have new skill.
Does it?
Oh, it does.
Oh, nope.
I think I upgraded everything.
Yeah, everything's been upgraded.
I just gotta wait until my other stuff.
Oh, I have this.
Damage!
Always damage.
I have this too.
White stun.
I'll be stunned for this.
And then...
Damage!
That should be good.
Okay.
That sucks.
I can't believe Brock is dead.
I lost my upgrades.
You're back.
And also Brock being dead.
Good.
It's time.
Time for what did I ask?
Time to unite the realms against Odin once and for all.
Tear try to unite the realms.
The real Tear.
Everyone loved him.
And even he failed.
Then we better not fail.
Or there will be no one left to try.
This is...
And Odin's already heard every blasted plan we have.
Yes, we've lost the element of surprise.
More than that, we have only one way to Asgard, and it's not
subtle.
You're Lord.
It means we enter from Tyr's temple here.
Asgard's wall is here.
Odin's host of Ayn Harjar will hold the space in between.
Which means we need armies of our own.
As many as will answer the call, numbers Odin won't see
coming.
And that's just to reach the wall.
To breach the wall, we'll need to find Sartar.
Ratatasker was able to procure this.
What's this?
That's an egg.
The three of us will go.
I know just where to look.
Splendid.
Allies then.
Who do we think we can get?
I'll venture to Helheim.
Try to recruit the army of the dead.
I'll return to Alphheim to unite the elves.
But just like that, unite the elves after centuries of war.
Well, they really like me and Alphheim.
and you to that I'm yes to find Siegren and muster the free
Valparais that good has no army nor Nifulheim nor Jotnheim
that leaves only Svartalfheim I'll go to Svartalfheim Sindri
huh Sindri are you sure I said I'll go he sped run the five
stages of grief so be it he's doing it I told you guys good
luck He's gonna use his anger.
This is good.
He's ready to kill.
Oh, I don't think, guys.
Most certainly not.
He's speed running.
Yay!
I almost envy everyone else's impossible mission.
Okay, that's good.
We still have upgrades.
I was gonna...
I thought, like, my upgrades are just gone.
I just wanted you to know if you need anything at all.
I'll be around.
Guys, look, see, Brock's back!
Yeah, I know we're all busted up inside today, but, you
know, I for one like to keep busy.
Alright, nice.
Yeah, I was gonna...
Time to cleave some hands.
Yeah.
I have everything.
No, I have to upgrade my spear, too.
I'll make Odin's spear look like a toothpick!
I'm gonna keep my runic one and a little one nope just me oh
my gosh thank god we can still upgrade like I actually got
worried that we won't have upgrades anymore it fits nice oh
shit wait yeah actually yeah fuck it I'd rather have all
strength actually huh what huh 62 defense does mmm nah it's
fine okay strength runic luck
mmm i'm just gonna upgrade this
Lucky good.
It fits.
Alright, nice.
Okay.
Takes away my runic and my cooldown.
Or do I just upgrade it?
I like the runic and cooldown.
That's the one thing.
I think I'm just going to upgrade it.
Now go show it all.
It fits.
That's why I liked it here.
Woohoo!
Lucky good.
It fits.
Alright, nice.
Okay, I gotta make sure we...
Is my nipple showing?
Yeah, it is.
There we go.
That's the one thing we gotta be sure.
Banana, thank you.
This is for chatting.
Thank you.
I was gonna say, why do the elves love him?
Oh, I literally think he's the hottest person they've ever
seen and made him the king.
The second he showed up.
as long as long as we free the nipple that's all that
matters that's crazy i guess because he looks like lee pace
or pace lee
he's technically an elf in lord of the rings if you think
about it guys he's an elf there
He's a king of elves and Lord of the Rings.
You said you know where to look for Cerder.
Yeah.
I unlocked the secrets in the shrine when I was in Moose
behind with Thor.
Don't worry.
He didn't see me go in.
That was not my worry.
Now look, when we find Cerder, we'll have to convince him to
combine with his wife.
Sinmara.
Combine.
Yeah.
When the two of them, uh, join, they'll create an enormous
Asgard destroying monster.
oh my I legitimately thought with Brock dying and Sigfried
mad at us they just like locked the upgrades they're like
GG's my thinking is that she may be more amenable to
speaking with a member of the like deceased there's like oh
you these are the stuff you have you're needed or death is a
skill now I suppose these two can survive a bit without me
brother if you wouldn't mind there well many things all
right goodbye guys finally peace and quiet
like geez no more upgrades you just gotta live with it his
wife where is she need for a lot i think
that would have been funny though like you just don't have
upgrades anymore I'd like live with your mistakes, boy.
It would have made it even sadder.
Oh my god.
I was gonna say, are you fucking kidding me?
and decided to isolate themselves in their home realms to
fight it.
Understandable.
Hopefully they'll understand why Ragnarok needs to happen.
That's right.
Oops.
You know what?
That's the way we have the broken moose behind the seed we
found.
We can take it to a Mr. Gateway.
Maybe we'll find Sutter's combat trial.
There you go.
Boy, I don't think we have time for that.
We gotta save the world.
Look, over there.
feel like his death would definitely have hit harder.
We just just don't have just don't have upgrades anymore.
It just gets too real.
Are you serious?
Oh my god okay I was gonna say
do you mean i literally thought like i just don't have i
just can't use
yeah i was like oh it's because he's lying down on the
ground the forge might be past this lava fall you know this
when i was here before i saw something that looked like a
forge anyone
The trial is with the one that Thor did.
Yeah, no, we don't have to do that.
You know, the fucking blind spot crouching.
No, he crouched.
Who knows how they're going to feel about it now?
You would try to force these primordial beings into
submission.
Well, I don't know.
We can't win this war without them, right?
We gotta be close.
I can get the forge.
Wait, how do I...
Oh my god, not again.
God damn
it, not again.
Not again.
Alright, let's figure this out, boy.
Okay.
And this touches it.
It doesn't touch it!
Okay, there we go.
I don't know how we're going to get that one, though.
I mean, I'll get that.
No touchy.
Like, what would touch it here?
Is it touching?
I guess so.
Oh my god, I'm not fast enough.
Oh, it doesn't matter.
Oh, use the fire that's already burning.
But like, how am I...
If I use the fire, I can't even reach that fire, though.
That's the thing.
I can't reach that.
Elka.
like this oh I didn't know that okay that's cool okay that's
cool all right I get it
one two three and then there you go oh cool that's
convenient oh
and think of this super chat thank you you should definitely
play expedition 33 it has tons of potential doki please
moments it would be a lot of fun the thing is i'm not really
i'm not a fan of jrpg type silent oh my god not you again oh
my god or like rpg type games in general they take a long
time to finish
i'm very bad at them
long dude it'll take me forever to finish
all right it's fine that's right i got you now
okay boom final strike oh my god where did you come from
There you go.
It's just not my type of genre.
In general.
More of an action gamer.
Are you fucking kidding me?
He had no shit on him!
Yes, boy, I have eyes!
You are a father, father!
And I'm like, yes, I know I am burning right now.
Like, boy, I can see that.
We got to take out these springs.
Where?
Oh, it's here.
Maybe there's a spring there.
It's five.
There we go.
We did it.
All right.
Nice.
I was like, where is the last one?
Really sweaty Let us find Sirte
Oh my god It's loot for days After going to that Whatever
the fuck the boss island was All the other bosses are so
easy We will ask I already had experience fighting that guy
In boss island
Alright give me the fucking money Yeah, the boss got lit.
Alright, let's grab all of these.
Oh?
We can also bring my giant dog, too.
To the war.
Want to join my army?
We seek a fire giant.
Go away.
Oh!
So?
Oh, shit, this guy.
We deal with these first.
Oh, my God.
Yes, no, I...
Revis, stab!
Oh, my God.
What do you mean another one?
What do you mean?
Oh, no.
This is so bad.
Oh god.
I'm just gonna start poking.
Oh my god there's too many.
It's okay.
I got infinity frame cutscenes.
Oh my god!
He blocked it!
Please.
Are you fucking...
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
Are you fucking...
Oh, I'm so sad.
I'm so mad and I'm so sad.
Okay.
Oh my god!
Now's your chance!
Are you fucking...
What do you mean?
It's my chance!
Oh!
Oh my god, I have to hit these guys.
Oh my god, he lied to me.
It was not my chance.
Okay.
There you go.
That's it.
Give me the cutscene!
Oh my god, it's okay.
Okay, we're still alive.
We're still alive.
Man, if that is Serger, he's got a lot to answer for.
As you said, we need him.
Oh, all right, we're back.
Anyway, as I was saying, do you want to join my army?
I won't help you.
What?
Why not?
Who you seek?
And what's left on him?
these bad giants I don't want to what elaborate oh you know
that right because you've got so much to live for not me her
so what's the point of all this you keep supper from sinmara
just so you can sit here and wait to die at least if you
joined with her you'd be together again we are together
huh oh she's got mine it's not much it's so romantic it's
enough but you're not even have you ever been in love she
doesn't want to lose him and she doesn't want to lose her
it's pretty good you know bro you know the love is pretty
good you know he must die i figured no he's right so he is
pretty good you would him Sorry.
Yeah, he doesn't want to sacrifice her heart for this if he
does.
Gus, thank you, this is rich out.
Thank you, thank you.
Wow, do he can't go up to people, ask them, are you fucking
to their face?
May I see them?
Yeah, there's primordial fire in those.
They are not of these lands.
Shouldn't matter.
what could work what could yeah put those in here what and
I'll become your monster but I don't want her involved at
all but the prophecy says you two have to combine sure this
will work what have I got to live for and then but then
you're chill you'll die and then how would she live go on
not here follow me what about the heart he's willing to die
for her but then she suffers the worst fate because she has
to live on without him i
feel like that's worse spark of the world it's like when cup
when one has to uh one dies first before the other and at
the and usually like the um the other usually dies not soon
after because they can't live without them
uh starter still me better than walking what awaits us
better than walking yeah broken heart syndrome
Yeah.
You'll like it.
But what'll happen when you change?
Don't know.
Won't be me anymore.
But how will you, or, um, future knew you?
No one to attack Asgard.
You got the horn.
Right?
Yeah.
Then we're good.
Oh hey, free item.
Okay, he doesn't need this anymore.
Yeah.
What was it like?
Wow.
So, here it is.
The spark of the world.
This is beautiful.
It's so pretty.
This feels too easy.
It does.
He knows you have the mask.
After killing Brock.
It's beautiful.
It's like the universe.
What other choice do we have?
None.
He knows that too.
This is it.
What about Simara?
Should we at least tell him?
Yeah.
It had hurt her too much.
More than not knowing what happened to you.
But you have to mix.
Making sacrifices.
Choosing the lesser pain.
Oh.
That doesn't make any sense.
You've never been loved, boy.
You'll stay away.
Damn!
Yeah, I would.
Sorter, is stabbing you with the blades gonna be enough to
create this new you?
Sinmar's heart is cold.
So beautifully cold.
Your dad's now got my fire in those blades.
If enough of me and the sparks fire, go into enough of her.
That's how they'll combine.
Okay.
Wait, but then he said don't hit the heart, though.
And she'll never know what happened to him.
That's so fun.
Bob, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Blades.
This'll hurt.
Oh, shit.
huh but
a really painful part my fire her heart combine them you get
ragnarok oh it's time it's ragnarok time oh
Oh, screams in painful ecstasy.
Oh, I...
Oh.
He definitely enjoyed that, guys.
Oh, my...
How long do you think this is going to take?
He's like, yes!
Yes!
Oh.
Where's the Valkyries?
But it's the one that Odin was talking to earlier.
Odin must have said that.
Yeah, he was definitely a three.
That's right.
I got you now.
Okay, you got me too.
That's right.
Okay.
What?
Where's my...
Okay, one of you guys will get close to me.
me oh
I thought okay I thought I dodged that I guess not what okay
that should have been a dodge oh shit oh my god I didn't
even realize you could do that what What?
Okay, I really need that actually.
He's not weak, he's my son!
I did not raise the weak child!
Jesus Christ.
What?
What the fuck?
Oh my god, he's coming over, isn't he?
Don't worry, don't worry.
Don't worry.
Tell me.
We could really use the hand right now.
Yeah, no shit.
I do too.
Okay, that's not helpful.
Here
we go.
Okay.
Please stop him.
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm getting out of there.
Oh, I'm getting out of...
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh.
Oh god, that's scary.
All right, there we go.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh god.
What do you mean, traitor?
I don't even know who you are.
Oh god.
I'm trying to help myself!
Oh god, I am so fucked up right now.
My god, did it stun him?
Oh, okay, it's fine.
Are you kidding me?
There we go.
Oh my god, he summoned the wolves.
Boom!
Savvy, Savvy, Savvy, Savvy!
There we go.
That's five.
Glad that they share HP, thank god.
Oh my god.
I was just one...
was one away.
I was one heal away.
Get away from him.
Daddy smash.
Bam.
Don't make me angry.
Pat my Anki juice.
Dad and Bear.
Oh, fuck.
Yeah, she can't fly no more.
Oh, yeah.
Never
that's right my son's a bear
all right we did it did it work I hope so our entire plan
lies around him becoming the Asgardian monster father over
here see is he alive oh
Will you help us attack Asgard?
Oh, God.
Oh, my God's Ragnarok.
Uh, great.
Hear that?
All we have to do is call him with Gallowhorn when we're
ready.
Title drop.
Let's head back to Moospline.
We can take the Mr. Gateway back from there.
All right, we got Ragnarok.
John Ragnarok has been summoned.
It worked.
I can't believe it.
John Ragnarok.
The roll credits.
Pat trusted.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, I mean, that's two less Valkyries.
It took a long time to train, so two less Valkyries for him
to command.
Think about it.
We're going to show up to Asgard and Ragnarok's going to
come in and wreck everything.
Odin won't stand a chance.
We're going to win.
Groh is right.
Groh failed to predict what we would sacrifice.
in return maybe she could only see the big stuff this is
gonna work right hope so we're sacrificing a lot of things
they will revive oh yeah they'll be undead Valkyries hey
check out that cliff earthquake must have shook this place
up enough to make a ledge trying to finish the job is after
he started all right but that thing is he doesn't know I
will finish the job that's right I'm finishing my job use
everything all right can you get closer
That's right.
Get buried!
There we go.
That's right!
Only one bird in this town!
Alright, now we kill the baby.
The baby man.
Get out of here.
fucker miss.
Alright.
Up we go.
You fought on a lot of wars, right?
You've never had anything like Ragnarok on your side?
I have.
And the creature does not guarantee our victory.
Right.
Alright.
Time to climb.
Thank God for my dead wife's drawings.
She knows I'll be lost without her.
I want to wait when she found the time to draw all of this.
Another earthquake.
This whole place is going to fall apart if those keep
happening.
Oh?
Where?
Watch this!
Boom!
That's right!
Feeling embarrassed now!
Oh shit, okay, never mind.
I got rage.
That way of taking up a lot of my HP.
There we go.
Holy shit, there's a lot of people waiting for me on the
other side, though.
I see him.
Let me get him first.
Yeah, I know behind me!
I can't do anything about it!
Oh my god.
What do you want me to do?
I'm just going to put 20 of these sticks on them.
There you go.
Oh, God.
There's more in front of me.
I saw them.
I'm just going to be over here.
I'm just going to wait here.
Oh, headshot.
Headshot.
Holy shit.
Wait, that landed all head.
do i do oh okay that wasn't he wasn't part of the team
all right i'll go back father the ainer you are aren't going
to stop attacking anytime soon we need to get back that's
what i'm trying to do boy i don't know what you were
thinking i'm doing but that is exactly what i'm trying to do
This feels different.
I had hoped my days of ceaseless battles were over.
I had hoped to never see my son go to war.
Oh.
Vigilance can break through their shields!
That's right.
Capture through stabs!
I know.
Holy shit.
Ragnarok is here.
They know what that means for Asgard.
What the fuck?
He just got on a new...
A new guy just got on top of it!
That's cheating!
What the fuck?
Bro!
A new guy just got on top of the tiger!
Okay, I got it.
Okay, I got them in the corner.
There we go.
Girl.
No more mouse for you!
A new pet.
A free pet.
That's fucking right.
There we go.
That's right.
Get out of here!
Get out!
before anything else shows up the gate is just through this
crack in the rocks when you're ready all right wait through
the cracks in what here oh it was right here i was literally
fighting for my life it's my turn to ride it ragnarok has to
happen the price we and others paid for this war's high it
will only get higher it'll be worth it oh
Okay, up we go.
Did I miss the loot?
And yes, my usefulness to a certain bany of nookie did run
out.
What loot did I miss?
There was a lot of shit over here.
I killed a lot of things.
No?
I don't think That's loot.
Guys, that wasn't loot.
That was my weapon.
That was my bullet, guys.
I was like, guys, I am pretty sure that's not loot.
No, no.
It was two guys.
Two guys.
No, the loot.
You broke the loot, Toki.
Ragnarok awaits our call as do the armies of hell thanks
mostly to me it seems war is upon us at last
all right it's time to start war this could be our last
chance father no it's all right i'm ready for war nope i'm
ready for war oh fuck sorry i pressed circle
i'm ready
see well this is it then the beginning of the end the end
for Odin and after that a new beginning for the rest of us
Atreus I know I'm just looking forward to seeing all the
realms finally standing up to him elves and dwarves and hell
itself you are so certain they will unite they have to after
everything they've been through they have to don't they
that's true they've been under the tyranny of odin for so
long they can make their new their own prophecies and
destiny you want to do you know while we still can nope and
the others are still making time for war so there's time is
that the other no it's all right it's war time no more
distractions boy wait another berserker gravestone oh yeah
all right let's you know what one distraction All right,
here we go.
Last side quest.
One last side quest.
All right, nice.
He can actually get stunned.
That's what I like to see.
Okay, that's unlucky.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, never mind.
Oh, never mind.
not get stunned there I thought she would get stunned but I
guess not okay
I got my half HP back at least
there you go oh my god fuck there you go oh my god that was
scary I
am definitely not I don't get!
Fuck.
I'm really...
Oh, close!
Ah, that was close!
Oh!
I was trying to get- do- um...
I was trying to do the L1 triangle and then she fucking
made- dude her move shit.
all right i'll start with this first
all right let's hope that hits
all right nice
what that's bullshit that that didn't hit
All right, nice.
Okay.
Oh my god, god damn it!
Okay, there you go.
All right, nice.
Nice.
All right.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
All right, stabby, stabby, stabby, stabby, stabby, stab!
Oh, fuck, I did it again!
That's fucking sucks.
I fucked it up.
Okay, I got...
All
right, nice.
Yeah!
What?
I was like, all right, yeah, there you go.
There you go.
First, second try.
This king he's not worth wasting my breath over his
berserker champions even less so try what king Why wait
until now to speak of them?
Oh, nothing to be done Finding that help change things.
What do you mean king?
It's clearly this king is weak as shit if she can't guard
you But Because it said one HP and I was like, huh?
brother about the oracles of your lands would you say they
manipulated events what's that did they have an agenda i do
not doubt they held their own interests first but in my
experience they could be easily fooled by their own
prophecies yeah what is a king to us god exactly once you
got you got nothing on me means to break my bondage to aries
but enough It's time for war.
For God of war.
I was kind of hoping to see some of them here.
When all the realm towers open at once, we'll see plenty,
lad.
Odin won't believe what's coming for him.
No.
Odin had lifetimes to prepare for this.
Whatever grows deception, he heard the truth as tear.
Do not underestimate him.
Rousing speech, brother.
Very inspirational.
Wow.
The Valkyries look different.
Welcome back.
Hilda Svini informed me of your success.
We've been planning accordingly.
Well, what would Ragnarok be without Ragnarok?
Are you wearing like masks?
I see the Valkyries.
Better than that.
They are reborn.
Reborn?
Oh.
Small amount of Vanir magic.
Their shield maidens now.
Nice.
Oh, nice.
He came through.
The elves called a truce to unite against.
That gives us an advantage by air and with hell's army for a
vanguard.
Oh, their wings are so pretty.
Will the dwarfs fight?
We haven't heard from him.
But there's time yet.
And I think we have what we need to clear a path for the
Ragnarok beast.
Well, when you say it like that, why worry at all?
Their wings are so pretty.
They're like...
Threstles.
Threstle wings.
I wonder you guys know that type of bird.
Species.
But I always love their wings.
Pretty woman.
Or Crestles?
Crestles or Crestles?
I think it's Crestles, right?
Alive.
Oh.
Yes.
I wasn't myself when last we met.
I'm glad you're safe.
My queen, the shield maidens will be divided among the
forces breaching from Alphheim, Hellheim.
in here in midgard we stand ready kratos atreus please
excuse me oh good night then oh remember's like what about
me we count on them oh she doesn't want to talk to her ex
then we all know what we signed up for our plan is only
missing i know i was like oh Mimir, I don't think you can
get...
I think it's over, Mimir.
And the respect of your troops.
And you have faced this enemy before.
I held his invading army to a stalemate.
This is our invasion.
A siege on his terrain.
I want our most experienced wartime general in the field.
I don't care about the honors.
I don't care about the prophecies and champions.
I just need us to win.
Freya.
I know what I'm asking.
Just...
Sleep on it.
It's so sad.
His ex doesn't want to talk to him.
He's like, I know I'm just ahead.
But I still got it.
She's not going to take you back, bro.
You fucked up.
You fucked up, man.
I love their designs.
They're prettier than the evil Valkyries.
Well, not her.
Her mask is a little fucked.
But everything else is really pretty.
not her mask but everything else is her mask is so creepy
though
oh they're so cold
mask i have a fear of like masks i think they're like like
the the creepy ones not like the robotic android mask but
like wow thanks but like tribal masks because like i told
you guys the story right uh when i was little my parent uh
the the stairs leading to like the um the basement floor um
they would have this tribal mask hanging on the wall and
it's not just one tribal mask it's like a collection of
tribal masks hanging on the wall and every night time when i
like walk down the basement because all our game consoles
are down there and our PCs were down there and it was just
hanging at the staircase where you have to go down and go
up.
And I was always super freaked out about it every time
because it would be like midnight.
It would be like not midnight, obviously, because I was a
kid, but it would be like you're super dark and I see those
masks staring at me and I freaked the fuck up.
And I remember there was a museum exhibit.
I would go to a museum and when I was a university student,
there's just like a famous museum in the city I visited.
and it's like all dedicated to aboriginal art and aboriginal
mass and everything and i was like freaking out i went
because they have like a whole section just dedicated to
that and i actually almost had a panic attack because i was
like it was it like the lighting and everything like gave me
a panic attack because i was so scared i was so scared of
all the masks everywhere and i was gonna come alive and kill
me It was like a Toy Story moment.
I thought all the masks and the totem poles were going to
come alive and talk to me and kill me.
Like, I don't know.
That was a university student, too.
It's because of the trauma of when I was little, where my
parents put all the mask on the staircase.
And it was dark, and then it would be nighttime.
And now I got to look at it.
would see it when I go down and go up.
So I had like trauma growing up from here.
And my friend would be like come on.
I want, this is so cool.
I want to see more.
And I was like, I'll wait for you.
I'm going to wait for you outside.
Because I couldn't.
I literally walked in.
It was like really, it was well decorated and everything.
And I saw everything, like all the mass surrounding like the
totem pose.
And I had a panic attack and I was like, I'll wait for you
outside I can't I can't be here I can't be here anymore then
they give the super chat thank you thank you I'm okay
looking at pictures but like if I see it in person like
pictures I'm okay but when I see it in person like I it like
I just unlock a fear like my deep-seated fear emerges thank
you the super chat thank you thank you my parents had a
glow-in-the-dark alien head that they hung in my room as a
kid i'm still scared of aliens thank you the super chat
thank you thank you my mom was obsessed with dolls and then
she because like she loved dolls growing up so she got me
she like bought dolls for me i was kid i talked to this
story before and then she bought a life-size doll and would
have like a um i would have like a floor slash wall
dedicated to all have growing up and then she put a
life-size doll like a child life-size doll that opens and
closes their eyes if you lay them down and stuff but then
obviously she's standing up and she would stare at me when i
sleep because it's just staring across from me it's like
literally across from my bed so like when i wake up turn my
head to the right i will see the doll and she there was like
a life size child size doll that was like a little like my
height and i was so freaked out i put her in clothes are in
the closet right so every time i open my closet i would see
her staring at me and i and i would see the doll staring at
me when i open my closet because i couldn't sleep in my bed
with that doll like looking at me but then my second thing
is i had to put in the closet
my apologies i have a lot of trauma coming from my childhood
That follows me to adulthood.
And that's why I do not fuck with dolls.
Lifestyle.
Like, you know, like the...
Not like, not the cute ones.
The cute ones are fine.
I love Monster High and shit like that.
But I do not fuck with, like, dolls that look...
That have, like, uncanny valley shit.
Lord Corosis.
Like, small dolls are okay.
But life-size dolls.
No, no.
I don't fuck with that.
Yeah.
Lord Kurosus, thank you for super chat.
Thank you.
My parents bought my sister a bunch of porcelain dolls and
her was performed by the stairs.
As a kid, I used to run past the open door as fast as I
could to avoid the dolls looking at me.
Thank you.
It was super chat.
That's so real.
With the mask, I would do that.
I would just run down the stairs.
So I'd like be like, if I'm, if I, maybe I can run faster
than this, the mask.
If they come alive,
down the stairs and up the stairs because my room was on the
third floor and the basement was the basement floor I count
basement as the first floor by the way so like after I'm
done in the like the gaming room cuz our basement was the
gaming room it was all our consoles and PCs so I would play
on the console my dad will play on the PC and then oh my god
oh yeah silly story I yeah yeah I'm here yeah he's got one
last day he still got his mouth guys he's tell silly stories
to tell silly stories Mimir my god you still got it he's
getting stoned today I forgot where I was I got distracted
because Mimir got game banana they give a super chat they
can thank you I already forgot where I was at my story oh
yeah the gaming room yeah so obviously when I'm done gaming
I have to to bed my parents be like time to hit the bed i
had to go to the third floor so i ran that fast as i could
at nighttime my house was so scary my childhood home was so
scary we did not have enough lights boy
and thank you for the super chat thing thank you what the
disembodied tongue do
bray that is fucking scary that is scary as hell i would
have just two the batteries out before they're that my
sister got licensed and that will put all her stuff
including that doll in the trash bags oh come on cuddle up
cradles come on give your boy a hug
men fine we'll tell you a story if
i fall asleep to finish it tomorrow oh story time of course
oh because they did like being like there will be a tomorrow
you know trying to promise a tomorrow
this like there was an old man who chopped wood for his
village every evening he bore the logs on his back and
delivered with them to his people but the logs were heavy
and he grew weaker as time went and one day he threw down
the logs as he could no longer bear their weight
and he called for death to come to him it's not a very happy
story dad
oh what happened when death arrived what happened i was
gonna say that's not a very happy story
what did you do
oh this is last day of the sun
he's the only one who ever got my high-brow sense of humor.
What?
Damn fine woman she was.
Apart from her taste in men, of course.
Huh?
She was a special woman.
She wanted to protect people.
What's going on?
She was here.
She saw every step we took before we took it.
Like she was always with us.
Watching over us.
Why am I dreaming about people talking about my dead wife?
Huh?
Hey.
Is my request upset you?
F.
Is a natural part of life, my love?
I wish only to be prepared for when my time comes.
Oh, the yellow paint!
We
mortals must do something.
things i am glad to have you prepare with me
oh yeah she's making the barriers which uh archaic destroyed
earlier you were quiet i have nothing oh my god thank you
for the 50 gift the chips thank you so much thank you i
would have chosen different Oh.
Oh?
Thank you so much.
I really appreciate it.
In my land, we in tomb our loved ones.
You would have me trapped in the ground for eternity.
I would have you close to me.
How touching.
My rotting corpse would bring you such comfort.
That's a new mechanic.
It's like we're touching hands.
He wants to...
tried to take charge of your ending did you know that was
different circumstance yes but not in purpose oh my god like
the the stare the glance she gave me though
that look she gave me when
toward distant future there is much time ahead of us i wish
to better a future that will exist without me day comes for
you and for our son we
will always walk together Kratos you will always be a part
of me I will always be a part of you and when you are gone
that part of me dies as well do you feel your absence
culmination of love is grief Please, Faye, we can't lose
another one.
We open our hearts to it.
When the pyre is spent, and you have gathered my ashes,
spread them from the highest peak in all the realms.
You will do this for me.
To grieve deeply is to have love.
fully open your heart to the world as you have opened it to
me and you will find every reason to keep living in it
he thinks about her every day
it makes me wonder if he does die like the prophecy says
then which afterlife does he go to does he go to spend it
with fay or does he spend it with his you know other dead
wife and kid
like does he have to choose what's going on it is time
i'll meet you outside father sir
base also whatever realm he is in well at least he gets to
spend it with fay at least he gets he gets to be with fay
after fly into battle with you one more time my queen me too
but not as your queen as sisters oh army mirror did you have
a good time are you ready yes i will be your general it will
be an honor to fight alongside as the god of war hi brother
i'll be right by your side
orders to the temple
honor what did she do
oh yeah first read this but friend thank you the super chat
thank you thank you my parents bought my little sister
cabbage patch kid doll because she wanted a one for
christmas the next day me and my four brothers jumped it and
broke it because it blinked once they buy it so yeah that's
the creepy shit i get you dolls that have like the blinking
stuff it's just too real all right we should be able to
upgrade my stuff because
thanks for grabbing this i guess like every day you have
seen century every day he has to live right now through the
grief of losing his wife i'm sorry linda i know you and bro
just tell me you're gonna get odin tell me whatever it takes
i wish she's blind Is she?
You will not.
Damn bright.
And if in the process you have to tear him a bucket load of
new holes in places he don't want him, I'll be rightly
obliged.
Hey, she's blind in one eye.
I just noticed that.
Alright, level seven.
No, isn't one eye?
One eye is like, you guys not see it?
Oh, look.
Look, see?
One eye.
white she's just crying I don't think crying makes one of
the eyes turn white
no see look her pupil is white on the other eye unless she's
like that's what she got a very lazy eye like that's one
lazy eye
All right, let's upgrade everything.
Oh, nice.
I'm almost at the final upgrade, too.
Now I'm going to go with Runic.
All right, let's see.
Which one do I have right now?
Okay, what does it...
It gives me...
Ooh, but my defense...
Is it worth it?
I could just upgrade this.
I'm just going to upgrade.
I feel like the Runic is...
The cooldown is just...
Actually, I can't upgrade it.
I'm gonna keep I'm not gonna oh okay wait um you don't have
anything new fate armor is free yeah but my strength though
I'm gonna keep my strength I'm gonna keep my strength
oh he's like she's carrying the tools wait is she pregnant
those nipples are very pointy
i never owned a female dog so i don't know honestly i've
never had a female dog before oh do you think it wise to go
off without stocking up i did
i don't keep please i was gonna say why i heard so pointy
sir General?
General?
Hey, bud.
Hey, buddy.
That's true.
It is cold.
Oh, we're back here.
Wait, can we still use it?
That tree is pretty fucked right now.
I came to these lands to escape my past, to start a new
life.
can hide no longer and hide your true self i do not want
this war it's ragnarok time baby we have suffered enough
we've been waiting for this exact moment prophecy did not
lead us here nor will it win this battle wars are won by
those that are willing to sacrifice everything If that is
the cost of vengeance, so be it.
Odin has taken so much from us already.
The realms have suffered enough.
No matter the cost.
This ends today.
If going out in the blaze of glory means that Odin burns
too, that's where I'll be.
A big, fat smile on my face.
Final speech, guys.
For Brock.
Last hurrah.
For Brock!
Oh, my!
All realms are open now.
oh
my god wait they're all here already
oh my god the elves yeah yeah
it's time the muspelheim tower has fallen and if odin goes
after niffleheim next they're trying to shut out raggedin
rock We gotta stop those war machines.
Oh, wait, that's Thor.
Oh.
Not an ideal start.
Wait.
Invi, we don't have time.
I know.
Just wait.
Huh?
Wait, is this...
Is that Ingrid?
That was her...
is his sword?
Well, we got work to do.
You three.
Follow.
It was his sword all along?
With me.
Watch our flags.
To the war machines.
Alright, we gotta go destroy the war machine.
This way!
Oh, that was sick.
That was actually sick.
Finding out that was his sword all along.
Oh, my God.
Don't worry.
I know.
Keep moving.
Oh, wait.
Oh, shit.
Give me a sec.
Yeah, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
I fucked up a little bit.
There's still time.
We have to...
Oh!
No!
Oh, the walls!
The sun and the moon!
Anger Bodo, I knew you'd show up.
Catch him later!
Oh my god, no!
I didn't fail!
It's gonna show up!
We have no other plans.
Our focus remains on the war machines.
Okay, wait, it's the...
Behind the Asgard Tower.
Without Raptor rockets, our only...
chance to break through the walls drink those floor you said
only sometimes you have to use it let's pray I was wrong all
right oh my god nice
what oh my god it's the fucking random ass bro it's okay
there
you go
Bye.
The last fight!
Right!
Final countdown!
The war machines, we use them to breach the flaw and strike
the city with our allies.
Sounds desperate.
Good, desperation is our advantage.
Would have preferred our realm destroying fire giants, but I
support desperation is better than nothing.
All right, grab, get him out of here.
okay down here and then up here
oh my god oh my god I thought that was the enemy Odin's new
Valkyrie queen is gonna oh my god I don't even know if the
dragon is his or mine
oh my god wait they were fighting each other
spider spider spy I couldn't tell!
They both have wings!
I thought it was the enemy bounce!
That's fine.
That's fucking right.
That's right!
Stop hitting each other!
Get out of here!
Oh shit, what the fuck happened there?
oh my god let's try it okay
okay that's fine
there you go
oh my god i was close that's right
okay Get out of here!
I got shield bash!
Hey, wait.
This way!
Alright, let me...
Oh!
Alright, up we go.
Yeah, I'm full HP now.
Alright, open that door.
Oh, wait, I opened that door.
Oh, it's not a door.
Oh, hey, he's here!
Curious!
You'll keep Thor busy at least!
Nice!
Oh, yeah, he's fighting Thor!
Oh, fuck!
Okay, now, yeah, now I know the dragon's definitely not on
my side, guys.
Now I know for sure.
That was, like, the only question I had.
Alright.
I was like, is he on my side or the enemy's side?
Am I supposed to go?
Like what?
Guys?
What?
Oh, okay.
Why the f- I couldn't- I couldn't drop down.
It was so weird.
Damn it!
Keep moving!
At least that army is already dead.
We're getting nowhere!
That works.
Yay!
Double kill!
There goes the Alpine reinforcements!
We are running out of armies.
We need Ragnarok.
After all.
different he is different but when i was away uh uh yeah the
a and hair yards why is he different my sisters and i must
sever it go there's still no sign of the dwarfs century
won't let us down we have to trust him raleigh or why is the
snake different for this form of hontawa
oh wait what that was the that was the actual giant Snake!
Hits him!
The what?
Oh my god!
That's crazy!
That's the snake that John woke up and is like, I'm a snake
now!
Holy boy, that's fucking hilarious!
He wakes up to find out he's a snake and is like, well I
guess he's like, I guess it's war time!
He comes!
Drafted to war!
That's fucking hilarious.
That's Ashley so funny.
He grew into what he actually grew into a giant after.
Yeah, no, we're not letting that happen.
Kanye kill him first.
No new pet.
Because That's drafted the war.
Damn it!
Ragnarok is supposed to be!
Why isn't he here?
Oh!
There!
That pillar is standing on the sweep!
Alright.
Oh my god.
Oh my- Yeah!
My dog!
No!
That Valkyrie follows us through the rope then!
Look at her friend.
She'll be fine.
We got more important things to worry about.
Even if we can breach the wall.
Perhaps it is better this way.
Better for who?
Alright, let's go up.
Oh, what the fuck?
I'm gonna take that.
Bomb and kill.
The dwarves are here.
The dwarves are actually here?
It's just Sindri.
And he's like, hey, guys, I have a name.
I'm not just Sinju.
I know I'm late.
Where is your army?
No more dwarves are dying for this.
Save it.
Odin forced them to build those war machines.
And I'm here to tear them down.
Before you break them, we must turn them on the floor.
Fine.
Leave it to the dwarves to clean up after the giants.
pulls through.
Wow.
You're gonna let the elves do all the work?
What happened?
What happened to the dwarves?
One cindry is enough.
Ragnarok.
By bloody time he showed up.
Don't worry, he's so angry, though.
What the fuck what is he doing you don't get to use us
anymore what the fuck more
or less what you wanted okay i didn't want this it's the
thing of the super chat thing thank you the Well, I guess
one sentry is enough.
Who are they?
I mean, guardians.
Odin took them in.
They shouldn't be here.
They're not soldiers.
Odin put them in our path to die.
It's war.
Oh, their key skill tripping.
him by those who are willing to sacrifice he's guilt
tripping and be like you killed innocent people
first war huh this is war boy what are you doing son listen
closely you feel better pain because that is who you are and
you must never sacrifice that never not for anyone i
was wrong matreus i was wrong open your heart open your
heart to their suffering that is your mother's wish and mine
as well Today's.
Today.
We will be better.
But...
What can we do?
Huh?
You see the sides of that thing?
I think we're gonna win.
Holy shit!
If they don't kill us first!
Oh my god, friendly fire!
Why have you stopped?
Stopped.
Ragnarok is here.
We finally have Odin right where we...
We will stop Odin.
But we did not come to sacrifice the innocent.
We will breach the wall at Hrimpur's floor.
With what army?
Petraeus and I will be enough.
That's suicide.
It may be.
But we will die seeking justice, not vengeance.
Can't that weapon break open the floor?
Only one way to find out.
You three.
Get those people to safety wherever you can find it.
We will see it done.
Prey and I will do what we can to slow Ragnarok.
Who was not mindless before?
See if he will listen to reason.
Odin will not get away.
That flying sword is like in Chinese mythology.
I know.
You guys know what I'm talking about.
Falky!
In those movies and TV shows.
No!
Attack him!
I will help those that are trapped and meet you at the fall.
Go!
Go, Atreus!
Yeah, you could fly just like that.
Oh, my gosh.
Arctreus tab.
Sanjuri, be careful and stay behind me.
You be careful.
Damn!
That's what I'm saying.
He uses his grief as revenge.
Oh, he's so hardcore.
Shut up and fight.
Holy shit.
Just shut up and fight.
He's so hardcore.
Damn, he's out for blood.
He's ready to throw hands.
Let's go, let's go.
Wait, what?
Oh, he's right here!
Here, okay.
I was gonna say, what am I missing?
It's like, why can't I open the door?
Channel that anger for revenge, Sindri.
You got this!
Oh, shit!
Letting control me.
Lay the beast down!
That's right!
No longer, whoa!
I'm a bear!
Holy shit, look at him go.
Holy fuck!
My angry juice upgraded.
That's crazy.
That's actually a lot of damage.
Oh my god, I'm not even actually, I'm not even using my rage
for this.
Holy fuck.
I'm just pure anger.
Our entire body is just anger now.
What?
You want to thank you?
No!
I just want- I don't care what you want.
This changes nothing.
Oh!
He does not give a fuck!
It's all biz- Oh my god!
You really had me believing you that we didn't have to be
enemies.
Dude, you're okay.
My mom was right about you all along.
You're a killer just like your father and you're here to
kill us all.
No, just Odin No, oh Sidry go she's a friend a friend
friends don't bring the end of the world to each other's
doorstep Loki damn You're right you're right.
I made some bad decisions.
He buried his ass It's not a defense.
I just want to make it right
Why wouldn't he be?
What are you talking about?
Odin is willing to sacrifice him at Guardians.
He put them along the wall to try and deter us, knowing they
can't fight.
Their deaths are just meant to slow us down.
Why would he do that?
And how am I supposed to believe you?
Because he's right.
It's who Odin is.
It's who he's always been.
Mom, where are you here?
What...
He'll sacrifice anyone at a problem in front of him.
The Magardians.
Your friend.
Our family.
Any of us.
I'd hope that your father would stand up to him.
But now it has to be you.
Your father didn't have the ball.
What are you saying?
I can do it.
I told you guys.
I told you she was going to betray him.
After finding out how he's really like.
these realms have ever seen but how would she get their
wings do you understand
I knew it I knew she was gonna betray him but our family
without Odin we can be one again a real one what he's doing
is wrong
okay buddy he said if we held our ground we'd be safe he
said we owed him you don't own your death no dad
will never let them get their grandfather then go with him
he'll listen to you are you ready to go find the recipe
people yeah i
love you mom oh the relationship got better oh finally
prepared the relationship
jesus what How can Dwarven Magic not do at this point?
Shoot it.
Oh, yeah.
Keep his brother alive.
You are fine.
Oh, whoa, Doki.
Oh, Sinji's just like, all right, let's go.
Sinji was like, he has a plan.
He has one goal in his mind.
Okay.
Who is the girl?
Hi, Sir Thor's daughter.
Thor's daughter?
I gotta rock!
Okay.
That's a great...
Rude!
You fight well!
My dad taught me!
That much is clear.
Yeah, well, wait.
Sorry, Peter.
He's not...
Holy fuck!
Get away from me!
No touchy!
That's it.
Send the wolves out!
There we go.
It's wolf time!
Oh shit.
Oh shit!
Oh fuck!
Okay, wait.
That's it.
It's time for spear of time.
I will use everything Target down what's going on I hear The
creature is not whole What remains is it?
I cannot fulfill its purpose What the fuck there's more?
That's right release the anger
Alright That should be everybody right
Oh my god, there is no more Yeah, I got random steam message
I don't even know who it's from Wait, where did you go?
He has done his part The rest is on us
Okay What's your lack?
Oh my god, I can barely see anything
Alright, bam You know what?
That's right.
Yeah, you want some of that?
Boom!
Oh wait, they're dead.
Okay, they're dead.
It's the steam third party.
Oh my god, it's burnt time.
You know the drill.
Only one burn in the god of war stream.
That's right!
Yeah, he's quick to die.
Holy shit, there's more.
It's fine.
I've said this out.
What?
Fuck this.
Fuck this!
You know what?
I'll do this.
Use everything!
Boom!
Alright.
Last bird standing.
Can you see that?
I love that.
Holy shit.
So easy.
Stupid.
I thought I heard like someone falling there.
Ring out.
Holy shit.
Alright, that's cool.
I'll take those.
Nice.
Oh, I got the slow-mo from that.
This parry.
Nice.
Left side.
Oh, it's over here.
I see it.
Alright, let's grab him out.
I believe it in his girlfriend on doing the rest.
This is like, this is the final foot.
The final countdown.
Yeah, she blitzed in.
Oh, we're almost there.
What?
Yeah.
I didn't want to listen.
I mean, we did that may not be our biggest problem right
now.
Oh shit Get back to your sister.
You must hold back right?
What happened to him before it is mine?
But if I could just take Atreus and the mask and do not look
back Oh, no, it's round two I trust you Stay away from her
Whoa I am done with you and your son Come back to it off you
back in time Because
DC'd No more fucking games And this time I'm allowed to kill
you Wait, what wait, wait, you didn't ask me to do this.
Yeah, I was gonna say wait Oh, okay, that's awkward Did you
ask my permission for this?
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
Give me a sec.
I...
Okay.
Thor, the last one seems to think you've changed.
Prove it and stop that.
Talking zone.
Wait.
Okay.
Oh what?
I dodged everything!
Oh my god.
He's fucking me up.
He's fucking me up, guys Here we go.
All right.
It's okay.
It's okay I don't remember no sink just like him.
He's struck.
He's not thinking
No thinking!
Just hit!
Don't act like you know!
Okay.
Oh, fuck!
Holy shit!
This fight is insane!
You attack my daughter!
No!
I did not do this to my home!
To my family!
Are you fucking kidding me?
How is that faster?
I gotta grab that.
What?
I'm fucking...
Okay, I don't know if you saw that, but I actually dodged
that.
I pressed dodge for that.
I don't know understand
Yeah Are you
serious okay
It's lightning don't you oh god, please not me though
Soon won't be me.
Let's go walk through.
Keep her name out of your damn mouth.
Okay.
Everything was fine before Loki showed up.
All right.
I can only do that.
Oh, and you focus up.
We almost convinced me.
Okay.
I've been believing things could change.
Listen to me.
You have nothing I want to hear.
Okay.
I'm trying to lock in.
Oh!
Oh my god!
That was so close!
Holy fuck.
Come on!
Ha!
There we go.
That's right.
Little does he know I have less thoughts than you.
What the fuck are you waiting for?
Your daughter.
My son He can't no think past me.
I tried to hurt her
That's right No one can out Don't think me
Head empty competition But your opponent is dokey I'd never
see the super chat Thank you What I've done Yes
But what will you do now
Change Change Yes, we can.
Look at me!
Change starts with you.
Oh, that's such a good line.
To move his brain in the West.
Mr. Broken Bond, the Super Chat think, thank you.
It must be better for our children.
That's good.
Why isn't he dead?
Are you talking?
Who told you to do that?
You don't talk.
You don't think I think you killed.
It's a simple fucking concept.
Ziff was right, by the way.
Holy shit.
I just didn't want to see it.
What is this?
Are you broken?
I am your father.
Take the hammer and kill.
Worst father of the year award goes to.
Thor finally realized his father never cared about him.
I didn't want this.
I did not want this.
No!
Wait, what?
They've done this to us.
Family
Looks like I got to do everything around here.
He just disappeared.
He got snapped Son you planned on it.
Why?
The room's gonna be fine.
I saved her and Dorr that one's on you Holy fuck You turn
them all against me Please Okay.
Okay.
Oh my god, a fucking course that hits me.
That's all he cares about.
started this fight no no no this all started long before you
showed up you are a no-brainer oh my
god there you go okay i have enough time
Okay.
No!
Yes!
Okay, I got it.
I got it in time.
That's fine.
It's fine.
I got it in time.
Here we go.
It's bad.
This is bad.
Okay.
What is he doing?
Oh my god.
I don't believe this.
Try it.
there Stop stop stop stop stop stop stop stop stop This is
not how it ends Okay
First try Oh All right, there has to be a second This is too
easy.
Was this everything you hoped for?
Was your plan really all that much better than mine?
I hope you got exactly what you want.
Huh?
Not quite yet.
He's just that weak.
Toki, he's old.
You're the only one who can craft a binding spell.
Huh?
I spent many long winters thinking about what I would say to
you.
As I watched you take your last breath.
Freya coming in with the steel chair and the kill steel.
I realize there's only one thing I need you to know.
You have no hold on me.
more oh that's my friend i forgot how good you look with me
damn oh
oh husband you always saw knowledge well now i'm going to
teach you what it's like to lose everything bow to your
queen I always loved you you know you've never loved anyone
oh why did you carry the mask boy you should have left it at
home I knew it.
I knew that wasn't the last.
That was only phase one.
That was too easy.
Oh, it calls for me.
You did it.
Loki!
No, no, no, no, no, no more fighting.
No.
None of that matters now.
This is your moment, Loki.
Groa tried to hide you from me, but this is your destiny.
Champion of the Yotunar.
Only he can put on the mask.
Only he can gaze into the truth of creation.
Unfold the secrets of life and death.
No more doubt, no more confusion.
You were born for this.
Put on the mask.
Do it.
Start a multi-million dollar franchise, Loki.
Ask it the question.
Okay.
Don't do it, boy.
This is your choice, son.
I trust you.
No!
Why did you do that?
What was it all for?
You choose to be nothing!
Yeah, but it was Loki's choice.
It was his choice to be nothing.
No destiny.
Attack.
you've waited a long time for this how did you freak that's
right it was his choice though holy shit there you go why is
this why is he just trying to kill me there's three of us
That's right.
I don't know what my math, what Mimir's gonna do.
But three against one.
Holy shit.
Oh, fuck.
That should have been a dodge though.
Get out of here.
fuck all right that that didn't hit any of my organs right
oh oh it's crows
oh my god everything i've killed for i just wanted answers
holy not the crows what do the crows do Okay, the clothes
were evil, but like, still.
Still is pretty fun.
Stop, stop, stop!
Stop!
Your shield could be of use.
Okay.
It's fine, I'm angry, though.
It's fine, I don't need no shield when I'm angry.
I need...
need anything when i'm angry that's right oh oh to choose
our own destiny old man that's right we make our own choices
this was our chance loki i could have had my answers i could
have learned the truth you took that away from me just like
how you took things from us we could have made the nine
realms better this was never about the realms or me it was
about you you destroyed everything my home no you destroyed
everything you did those things yeah choices you killed your
own son it wasn't my choice i had no choice there's always a
choice what do you mean we saw you stab him i didn't i
didn't do it he says with the knife in his fucking heart you
can choose to be better now I can I have to know what
happens next I will never stop then we'll stop for you why
do you have to say
He's going into the marble.
Put him in a snake.
He
took his soul.
He took his soul.
Now put his soul in a worm.
What do we do with him?
Honestly, like...
It's be safer than keeping the marvel.
I swore I would never rob from you the choice between life
and death.
I have waited so long for this moment.
And now that I'm here...
Then a pokeball.
I don't need this to make me home.
We stopped his madness.
That's all that matters.
Oh my god, boy!
Ah, no!
Sentry with the metal chair, with the steel chair.
Oh!
And he's gone now.
He killed Steel.
I mean, it's over.
Why is he still here?
And here comes Sindra, the Steel Abber!
Oh!
Follow.
Oh, nice.
Okay, follow me.
Quickly!
No, no don't sacrifice yourself.
No
They just got reunited
No, he's too pretty But your path is your own Follow it and
you'll end up right where you're supposed to be I like so
like basically he's just he doesn't even have an afterlife
now wake up atreus
hi where where is my father yeah so you can't answer the
souls are now forever rome you'll be glad to see you
thanks hair
that's crazy sinfred was like if my brother if my brother
can't go to the afterlife neither could you that's hardcore
we all get you that's so hardcore you literally just came in
took odin and then sent him to send him to rome forever are
there many survivors more than we could have hoped for
that's good oh she's never flying again wait actually yeah
her wings are fucked i'm afraid he was lost atreus all right
um thanks for patching me up Take it easy.
You took quite a beating.
She's still out there, you know.
Not for long.
Freya spoke about it earlier.
Where's she?
Oh, the other Valkyrie Queen.
Okay.
I was like, who?
Who's still out there?
Um, yes.
We lost the other brother.
Why is it?
Why are all the brothers?
dying mom stop it I'm fine hush through Loki I'm so glad you
both fuck are they eating you have no idea and I'm sorry
Thor he was he tried you know I'm sorry I couldn't do more
nothing will fix what you're feeling mm-hmm but I hope
There's some comfort.
It's a naked rabbit.
Knowing Odin's gone.
They are absolutely his.
Look, it was an honor to fight alongside a giant.
Know that.
Will you stay here in Midgard?
For a bit?
Then I've got something I need to find.
I'm working with Hilda's Vini to get the rest of the
Asgardians to Vanaheim.
Help rebuild.
Then I hope it can be a fresh start for that.
and you oh and through I hope you find what you're looking
for good luck see you Loki take care hmm no longer angry oh
I'm gonna oh I'm gonna I'm gonna eavesdrop on your
conversation not Not creepy at all.
All right.
Not creepy at all.
Let them have their R moment, you mean?
It's not A, it's our moment.
I'm part of this too.
I saved their lives.
All their moments is my moments.
Oh, yeah.
Ah, he lived.
His brother didn't.
Yeah, I saw his brother get choked to death.
Get this wood over to Brana's tent.
Skilled her?
Loki!
Hey, glad to see the head injury didn't make you forget me.
Did you have a head injury?
Everything was a blur.
Maybe that was someone else.
Anyway, man, I'm just... I'm really glad to see you.
I'm glad to see you too.
Nah, Crozer.
Are you?
That's what they want you to think.
Your friend's wolves have been helping out with hunting.
We should have plenty to feed everyone.
That's good.
No shit?
And hey, thank you for everything.
You wouldn't even be here without you and your friends.
Yeah, of course.
I...
I just wish we could have gotten more people out.
Loki, you did good.
Thanks, Skilder.
Take care, okay?
Hey, you know me.
Nice.
Our Chayas is...
We only lost one girlfriend.
We still have two other girlfriends and one boyfriend.
Oh, there he is.
And one for the kid, too.
Cole!
Here, here.
We wouldn't be here if it weren't for you.
And Freyer's sacrifice.
It's true.
Well, we were just...
Swap in our own frayer fables.
Right, right.
So where was I?
Oh, when we met, I was expecting this warrior, this master
planner, a born leader.
The legend came before the man.
But the man himself was very different.
He won me over, though.
He was just so damn kind.
And apparently very handsome.
Yeah!
was he you know the third the third on the thruple
does he the addition to their thruple gee they give the
super chat thank you thank you god of the dwarf coming soon
on some day in 2027 maybe
He was just so hot.
They would open the relationship just for him.
Who wouldn't swoon?
Oh.
I'm pleased to see you away.
Hey, Freya.
Freya.
It was his choice.
Wait.
My dad's still alive!
He saved us all.
I'll never forget that.
The family I thought I had was taken from me piece by piece.
But there's comfort in the family I've chosen.
Your mother was right, you know.
You grew into that bow after all.
That face united two races that's been in war with each
other for centuries.
They only took one very handsome man to unite them.
That's crazy.
I'm so proud of the man you've become, Atreus.
Thank you for everything.
Yay, new mom.
I should find my father.
You should.
Jacob, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Are you playing a built-in Valhalla expansion after this?
It's peak.
How long is it, guys?
Most likely I won't do it for this stream.
Glad to see you too, Amir.
Listen.
I want to thank you.
Oh, what else did you expect from the smartest man alive?
It's not just because you're smart.
You listened to me, mentored me, and, well, you're basically
another dad to me.
I need you to hear it.
I sleep.
I appreciate you so much.
I love you too, little brother.
See you, Mimir.
Bye-bye.
It's good to see you about Atreus.
You too, Heldus Vini.
Oh, how many dads and moms do I need?
Oh my gosh.
Oh, first girlfriend.
Aww.
Oh my gosh, she's the one.
If my dog likes her, she's the one.
Is that, huh?
Yeah, we know him.
Oh!
Hello!
This day is all surprising.
Well, you already have.
Okay, we gotta find two more undead dogs for the other one.
Other two.
Aww.
She's dog approved.
Huh?
Thank you for saving us.
oh my god they're holding hands guys oh my god you haven't
told your father yet have you told him about what yeah about
what come on giant visions i already saw it
Every part of me is telling me this is what I have to do.
I, I just, don't know how to say it.
Come with me.
I've got something I want to show you.
Both of you.
Oh, Dad.
Um, I, uh, this, this is my, uh, friend.
She's like, my very good friend.
Um, she's my, I'll say it's for you too.
Girlfriend.
She didn't say no.
She didn't say we weren't.
She wasn't my girlfriend.
I'm glad you are too.
So, what was the end of the story?
What?
Before Ragnarok.
You promised to finish it if I fell asleep.
Yeah.
Yeah, we made it.
Didn't think we were going to make it, did you?
he asked why the old man had called for him seeing death
before him caused the old man to reconsider his request
after a moment he asked that death help him lift the logs
onto his back so that he may continue on his journey he
wasn't ready to die he was to keep living there's a lot of
smoke out there hmm it seems when asgard fell pieces of it
landed all over the realms there might still be some ain't
her yard near them but yeah no that's not what i brought you
here to see yeah no you gotta live with that oh another
prophecy
and look the key more yeah no
wait that's me
mother what My
shrine in Yodanheim.
She destroyed it.
She didn't want us to know her fate.
We forged our own path because of her.
Oh.
She went against her own people.
Our people.
To protect you.
She wanted us to write our own destiny.
We don't all open.
I'm sorry.
Father, I...
I need to talk to you about something.
There are other giants out there, and I've got to find them.
I think I know where to look, but...
They're my responsibility.
I need to do this alone.
I don't want to do it alone, but...
No.
He's turning 18!
Does it frighten you?
Yeah.
That is growing up.
You must do it.
Like you taught me.
Yeah.
Growing up.
We survived today because of your choices.
Who to trust?
Who to call friend?
Son.
You are ready.
Oh.
He approved.
He's proud of him.
That he practically said I'm proud of you, son.
Loki, you will, bro.
Patreus.
Patreus remains.
Oh!
Remains in his heart.
you and son oh
my god he's crying he's trying not to cry he's like men
don't cry
would you see his face he was trying not to cry he's our son
oh he's like my new daughter-in-law
You'll be okay.
Boy has become man now.
Oh.
There's another side?
There's no way she didn't know about the other side.
What?
What is this?
Wait, that's him fighting war?
And then...
The God of War.
Oh, is this him leading the army?
This Kratos is trying.
There was another page in the test.
Oh, that's the past!
Or the future.
Or the future?
Well...
Is that the future?
Never imagined.
And what now?
There is much to do.
Oh!
But Kratos finally being worshipped.
He didn't think it was possible that he'd ever get
worshipped.
We'll see to it.
Together.
there
oh my
god can move okay
oh well that's cool
holy yeah the music definitely goes hard
I want the wrong one.
As his new Valkyrie queen, Avani your goddess, your friend.
Gana pledged loyalty to Asgard long ago and our friendship
ended soon after.
what happened i made a choice once she couldn't accept
kratos she hates me she will be a problem for us better we
find her than she finds us another
one for the big boy himself school i need to go to niflam
niflam all right
I suppose credits okay we
can hold a few dozen for camp families will stay together
obviously take care Kratos thank you no problem sorry about
your dead husband all the supplies we can although it won't
be much don't worry about it anyone who's able can head out
for extra supplies a seer and vanier together
yeah i mean thank you thank you congrats on beating god
award ragnarok yeah i didn't think i thought it would take a
lot longer i got a little worried oh and everyone was like
oh yeah eight hours i was like yeah but what if you take it
into account of dokey hours what would it be like 10 hours i
was like oh no so i'm glad it did not take 10 hours i was
ready to play for 10 very ready for it.
So, I skipped.
There were too many side quests.
Were you not entertained on Boss Island?
I did Boss Island and I was like, yeah, that's it.
I'm good.
I fought 10 bosses on Boss Island.
We could take care of any lingering business in the realms
or investigate those pieces of Asgard either way we are with
you brother
pause island was so yeah for you guys it was so fun I need
to find like uh I need to find the what was it uh we gotta
find a gate there you go I add the compass.
I think boss Island actually trained me for the actual end
game, like for the story bosses.
Brother, can we get back to what you were saying about the
Oracle of your homeland?
Yes, sis.
You mentioned trying to escape your bondage to Aerie.
Yes, but we will speak of this later.
Should I loot here?
Oh my god, where does this go?
I want, oh there's loot.
Oh, he knows.
Oh, wait, but he doesn't know about this!
There we go.
Know anything about the frozen dragon?
It was Baldus.
He took Atreus.
Try to escape with him.
We fought on its back.
The things he put you through.
Odin gave the commands.
The blame is his.
All right.
Let's fight.
Let's go to...
niflam nifham anybody here oh there she is
all right where is brock's funeral is that niflam or swar
swar damn where's the funeral we gotta pay tribute to brock
niflam i
want to go to here okay here Oh.
Oh, Brock's funeral is ending?
Which one's first?
First dead.
Oh, first is Nephlam dead in Brock's funeral.
Oh, wait.
There's something here.
What is wrong?
I don't know nothing.
It's just...
I don't know if you've heard it, but we're gonna say goodbye
to Brock in Svartal time.
Oh, there you go.
The funeral.
Yeah.
Remain at Rab's time.
She is blind in one eye, guys!
We will be there.
I think that's exactly what you guys didn't notice.
Okay, there you go.
Niflam first.
Alright.
No, she's just crying.
Oh, yeah.
I remember Max.
Max, he did even super chat the thing.
Thank you.
You're really good at accents for sure.
where do we go uh where are you yeah what is this a memory
of war you could use this as a training arena if you like
nope you'll just be fighting the recollections of enemies
nope that's all right
free are we free of the father our half-life now belong to
no other what the father Odin I presume I don't know but
there's definitely something more going on here oh this is
where we get all the Ravens oh I see I six oh I see these
are all the surprise a lot more Ravens than I expected not
realize I killed those that many
Ravens Ravens the ones we've been destroying Odin's little
spies honestly I'm surprised I even got that many I was not
I was not paying attention to them is this a prison it would
seem so let's continue might be something useful inside this
place goes deep we should head downward ah yes I'm sure
there's nothing especially dangerous at the bottom of an
guardian prison your master is no more be at peace
he does not know what peace is he's like what is peace
that's true though you don't need to do any of this anymore
i mean that's fine it might feel a little overkill but if
the aim harry are survived ragnarok Perhaps some of the
inmost did as well.
Let us find out.
Wait, there is...
Uh...
Fuck it.
Yeah.
Oh, shit!
Okay, I might need some help.
Alright.
Bye-bye.
Oh Got your shield back, but goodbye to your shield All
right, let's open this I see loot Dwarf I do not sadly of
course the in her yard disappeared a few dwarven rebels
during the occupation.
Oh Yeah, he's dead What the fuck what's the chain do I
wonder what the fuck who's groaning right now oh ah that's
what the chain do
who is this worth he's been dead for a while oh Is that what
the groaning was?
Was it him?
Oh, what the fuck?
That's it.
I'm angry!
Alright, get out of here.
I need my HP.
Okay, yeah, I think that groan...
Oh, wait, no, it's him!
Oh, it's a dark elf!
I don't think he's friendly.
Oh.
I thought I could let Yeah, I don't think he's He's gonna be
grateful Yep, I have a feeling Yep Steppy, stabby Steppy
That's right Maybe if you appreciate me Saving your life
That's on him We all saw him Try to kill me first guys We
all saw him This was self-defense Everyone Good.
Self-defense.
That's an elf, but not a particularly high-ranking one.
So what did Odin have to gain by imprisoning them?
Yeah, what the fuck?
I say information, but why keep them locked up afterward?
Yeah.
Oh, what the fuck?
Okay.
Yeah, I want to know more about what he was doing.
Self-defense, bro!
Oh shit, oh my god!
Okay, he did, she did so much damage.
I only got 43 XP for that.
That damage was insane.
Did he let me keep his weapon?
That is true.
I was like, damn.
Oh, I have to put this up.
What?
Oh, so I put this up.
And then put the other one down.
Oh, wait, that's...
Oh, to disguise himself as them?
Oh!
Wait, that's what it's for?
So Odin was the dark elf and the dwarf?
Okay.
okay all right where did he go oh okay careful brother just
covered him by far oh oh angry
okay not angry enough apparently use a shield strike brother
okay i don't think i can use my shield i don't think i can i
would love to Oh god, that's hope.
Holy fuck!
Oh
my god, they do so much damage.
They actually do so much.
Holy fuck, I'm not okay.
Oh no!
Oh my god.
How much do I have to do?
That's spoiler.
I thought that was like, oh, I was supposed to know that.
She was like, oh, I'm dumb.
I can't believe I didn't know that.
Yeah, I was like, damn.
I can't believe you guys knew that from just seeing the
prisoners.
I was like.
She was like, oh my God, man, you guys are so smart.
I didn't even realize.
all right nice okay nice these guys are crazy i
was like damn how did i miss it no no no no no no no no okay
holy fuck this guy isn't this guy is so annoying actually so
annoying oh my god i have to like wait i have an idea
okay this is my idea oh wait well he's dying so well that
wasn't my idea but it also worked i guess fuck i'm trying to
That wasn't my initial plan, but, like, it still worked.
Yippee.
Tear?
Freya.
I can't believe it.
Tear?
That can't be.
Oh, my God.
Is this an illusion?
No, brother.
No, I think it's the real deal.
Namir?
Is that you, old friend?
Okay, what?
think about war question one what are your thoughts about
war odin learns what you've done odin is dead the realms are
at last free of him you're safe odin's dead oh yeah there's
a accent on it so the reign of the ace here is truly over
that's quite a lot to take you how did he survive and you
are his name is kratos kratos oh my god he's real i i know
that name come You need real shelter.
No?
No, what I need most now, I think, is to reflect on what
you've told me.
I need space if you would grant me that.
Very well.
Our home is in the realm between realms for the moment.
You can find us there when you're ready.
Kratos.
I know you from somewhere.
Huh?
Wait, how does he know me?
I'm sure I will come back to me.
Until then.
Oh.
He's alive.
Okay, can we talk to him again, or no?
Oh.
The troopers didn't fail with it.
We have been pondered.
If I don't meet the war god of legend, he is different from
the one we thought we knew.
Yet he has been through so much, but he finds a piece he
seeks.
Oh, and the DLC?
Oh, nice.
All right, because I want to know if I want to know if he's
a bitch or not.
I can't believe he's real.
Oh my god, he's so tall.
I keep forgetting how tall he is.
Alright, let's go up.
Yeah, he doesn't look as happy.
It's hard to trust anything after what we've been through.
But with Odin gone, I have no cause to doubt it.
Our paths will cross again.
Of that, I'm sure.
Probably.
this up where to now go home oh we got go to the funeral so
was the dwarf and the elf were they also like did odin also
that way bump into like the other um did we bump into the
other versions of them like when he was the dwarf and the
else well now we know what this presence for this is where
he would camouflage himself as makes sense if you're going
to imitate someone you wouldn't want them walking around why
not kill them he must need them alive in order to assume
their form we still died in here like they wanted tier dead
for a multitude of reasons but he knew tier would be more
useful when did I bump it to the dwarf and the elf god of
war has truly returned what now the dwarf that spits at you
I'm trying to remember not that I need to remind any of us
of that oh
my god oh my god this is why i didn't kill all the crows if
they're gonna be that annoying the first time you enter
swanhand there's a dwarf on the bridge that was odin oh what
about the elf i
don't remember that that must have been like so long ago oh
was he the one that was like i think was he the one where he
sort of walked away Alpine desert there's something like saw
me and then walked away right good thing we didn't miss this
On the bridge just a random elf.
Oh
And I'm a dwarf on the bridge So I'm trying to remember
All right time Time to go to the funeral guys It's time to
pay your respect.
Where would it be?
Closest is...
Closest is this.
Gang boss.
What the fuck is...
Oh, is that the Valkyrie?
The Valkyrie that...
Uh...
That's...
Freya's ex-best friend.
Is that the gang boss?
Well, like, Freya deal with that.
I don't need to she's got to deal with her own problems.
I'm not getting involved with that I'm not getting involved
with a cat fight.
I watched the cat fight
I came by and took out an ain't hair yard patrol area should
be clear Can't speak for the rest of town.
Guess an occupying army is as good as a lockdown for tamping
down foot traffic
deal with that herself this way how do I get there
well I'm a little lost for this
wait no that's the entrance oh my god my map there you go it
didn't track it that's why I was so confused because like
the objective and the portal is both blue and I got confused
profane alternate lyrics to my balance absolutely disgusting
but now i wish i could remember some of them the paperwork
that man created for me i had to build a chest just for his
violations a big one i taught him 20 different ways to cold
forge a bolster once he taught me a slightly easier method
of wire pulling and from that day on his apprentice.
Oh, they're thinking about Brock.
They're reminiscing about him.
That's cute.
I mean, it's just in time.
Brock's behind me.
Oh, my God, Brock!
Oh, my God.
You just left him on the table?
I have met many on my travels.
You are one of the few.
I would call friend.
I always thought you were one of the dumbest Because I never
met he never solved his riddle This world is a darker place
for you leaving it We're taking him to the spared sands.
It's in the wetlands near the ferry We'll wait for you
there.
Don't you thought he was the dumbest yet he could never
solve his riddle.
Hmmmm I don't think he was the dumbest one
That's all I'm seeing Can't even solve the dumbest guy's
riddle.
Hmm.
What the fuck?
Are they still...
What the...
Okay, I did not expect...
I did not expect myself to be doing more...
Are you kidding me?
It's not like they're all dead.
That's a surprise.
Oh my god, is that an...
Ambush?
Is that another ambush?
Alright.
I'll just kill him.
Nice.
Thanks for you.
Well done.
I don't suppose more violence in the streets will convince
the citizenry that it's safe to emerge.
I'm just gonna grab some loot.
Thanks for the help, Freya.
I really appreciate it.
From the chief anti-Oden propagandist in Darlene's
Rebellion.
Quite a sharp witch he had until she found her by subtle
means of resistance.
Alright, back to where I was planning on going.
Just use it all up.
it's like here oh is this through here oh I have to go
through a port okay how far is this okay it's here where am
I okay wait where is it
oh my god what the fuck yeah I okay we gotta go to a portal
we gotta go to a portal okay all right we're going to a
portal yeah no i'm i'm walking back tp time oh my god i'm
lost i don't remember where where the fuck was the door
a door to the bar oh my god there's too many doors i don't
know where i came from i i'm actually i actually don't
remember i actually don't remember
okay we're gonna remove that i'm here how the what door was
it Which door did I come from?
Oh, no.
I legitimately don't remember which door it is.
I look directly at it three times.
Oh, my God.
I was pressing circle, but it wouldn't let me go in.
Okay.
This door.
other way oh my god it's the other way
if i check every door i'll figure oh my god it's this door
is oh my god it's not this door is it perhaps it's this door
you know what just destroy that or maybe maybe it's this way
Oh my god, it's this way, isn't it?
Oh my god, it's this door.
It's right here.
Okay, I figured it out.
I found the door.
There's too many doors.
There's so many doors.
And they're all so small.
Oh, these doors are so small.
Oh, small.
I found it.
I found the door.
I think by that time I would have made it to the funeral.
Already.
It was like here.
It's here.
Um, they're average for dwarfs.
There you go.
I like how because there's no dialogue anymore.
It's, like, super fast.
Alright, into the boat I'll go.
Wait, wherever it is.
Not that!
Oh, my God.
Wrong way.
Let's see.
Alright, there must be another boat, right?
I literally just went to that first boat I saw.
have been another boat on this side oh my god there it is
the other boat the other boat i forgot about i should have
changed sewn some mourning garb we're not dressed properly
i'm not dressed properly i typically require formal wear at
funerals brock certainly would not perhaps now you've got me
thinking of what i might look like with some jewelry around
my neck stump maybe some gold woven into my beard i'd be
quite fetching hey i am here thanks where they are brother
oh come on surely he'll be along it's his brother let's hope
so loss can do things to a man oh you made it we couldn't
again My bro
He doesn't wear gloves no more
I love you Bro
this guy is not He was too depressed I don't think this dude
has showered since Then Bro his brother's dead Oh
He had to deal with his brother's death twice
Oh Oh
Isolate.
It's so sad that he can't even meet his brother in the
afterlife, too.
Sindri.
Hmm.
Just like don't talk about Brock.
Like you don't deserve to talk about Brock.
Aww.
What?
It's bigger, the more you take away.
I figured it out.
He solved the riddle.
We're past that, bro.
We've been past that for so long.
Aww.
That's the line we ended on.
Okay, I...
Oh, brother.
I'm sorry, but he ruined the moment.
I love the riddle.
I don't think, I feel like him solving the riddle should not
have been the final words.
Now, Brock would have, that's true.
Brock would have wanted that, yeah.
I guess he would uh I just it it was yeah oh there's a hole
in Sindri's heart that's what yeah there's a hole in his
heart that's how he figured it out oh I get that it's just
it was it felt a little off for me
Yeah, the whole of their hearts, that's how he solved it.
I think, yeah, I guess, I guess Brock would have, yeah, I
know the mail for, uh, yeah, like, for Brock, for Brock, he
would have wanted it to be like that.
Solving the riddle when it's too late.
Because I felt like it was implied, because, like, you know,
Sindri lost something.
he he lost he lost like a part of him by losing his brother
and i was just like oh and then he was like oh i'm like what
they saw it's all right they just take my ad revenue it's
okay guys they just take my ad revenue and that's okay it's
it's okay Kyle, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You know, okay.
This is what I learned from...
I actually got an actual...
I actually got an actual strike on my channel, but it wasn't
for, like, big songs.
Yeah, it wasn't for, like, copyrights.
Like, it was copyright-related, but it was for my
anniversary song because one of the background music I
picked was from Small and...
was from an indie musician, but I bought the song before,
but I forgot.
I bought it for my old YouTube channel.
So, like, the license didn't transfer over.
So, I had to, so, like, they strike, gave me a strike on it.
And then, because it, like, gave me a strike on it, because
you're like, oh, you don't have a license for this.
I was like, yeah, I do.
And I realized it doesn't transfer over.
So I had to re-buy the license.
I had to, it was a BGM.
It was bgm um for like the outfit reveal and then and
because they took the video down they took the stream down
but usually bigger companies or big song companies they
don't strike copyright strike it they just do like you just
take your ad revenue yeah it was resolved they instantly
removed it when i bought the when i re-bought the license
and emailed them yeah that's usually how it goes usually the
um the bigger music companies they would they would uh they
would just ask for ad revenue like to just flip the ad
revenue for it but it's gone now they took it out down
that's why i like if i do get a copyright strike i'll just
edit the edit it out
i know that like it's it should be fine because if other
play have their playthroughs with the video up, then it
should be fine.
If other playthroughs have their videos up of the credit
scene, then I don't have to worry about it.
No, the VOD's back.
They literally reinstated everything.
I like the ending.
I think the funeral was a very nice touch for the epilogue.
But, like, it was just my personal opinion.
for him solving the riddle.
I guess, like, they're, like, Brock would have wanted it, so
I, like, that makes sense in my head, but it, like, broke me
out of, it broke me out of the immersion, right there.
For me, that was my personal opinion.
I know it's, like, the whole metaphor being, like, look at
Sindri, having a hole in the heart.
But, like, I sort of implied it from the scene itself.
Yeah.
It was, like, for me, it was, like, implied.
But I know for others, for them, they liked, uh, uh, For
others, like, it fit the scene because that's what Brock
would have wanted.
I get that.
But I enjoyed the game.
I think the writing was really, really good for this game.
And, like, the moments where it needed to be, like, very
feelsy, like, what's it called?
What's the word?
felt and stuff it hits really hard we're not going to do dlc
today i don't first i'm not sure yet if we will do dlc
because i felt like it ended at a really nice ending but
i'll think about i'll think about it because i also sort of
want to start a new series yeah when it's emotional it
really hits you the fact that they hugged in the end oh that
was so sweet the sun him and the It was very well written.
I really enjoyed the entire series.
I can't wait for the remastered.
I never played, I never played the original trilogy before.
So I really look forward to checking out the remaster
whenever it comes out.
I think like next year, right?
They said 2027.
And yeah, like I think the voice acting and direction and
the character development was really well done.
I just, everything was very well.
I can understand why this game won so many awards because
everything was just so well-written and well-directed, voice
direction and everything and well-directed.
Oh, the ending will end Kratos' story?
Oh, yeah.
I'll think about it for next week.
Next week, for sure.
But one thing to look forward to the next week that I've
fully confirmed is we are going to be playing Resident Evil
Requiem on launch because we have a sponsor.
for it uh from msi um and also from capcon well not a
sponsor from capcon they did give me a free game code as
well um so and they gave me they're sending they sent me a
creator package for it I think some of you guys already saw
it it looked really cool it was like some briefcase like a
metal briefcase or some shit so I hope I'm getting it I
don't know I I got I got an email about it like a couple
like a couple of months ago for it but I don't know if I
actually am receiving it package on Monday so I hope that's
the creator package because it looks really cool I saw some
people already tweeting about the pack the creator care
package um so I hope that's I get one because they asked me
for my address a couple of months ago um uh but yeah I I'm
gonna be streaming that next week um and um that's the only
thing I've confirmed for next week I don't know why week yet
um but I will be taking uh I will be taking a more relaxed
chill for next week because I do need some rest I've been
not I've been little burnt out I I will be admit I've been
not a little burnt up but I've been sort of burnt out from
from a lot from all the stuff going on I've been super
overwhelmed lately the last couple of months so um I'm
definitely gonna take Next week, a more chilled rest time.
Next week, I will be going, we're going to do a mine.
We're going to go back to the Doki SMP next month.
Next or not next month.
Next week as well.
We're going to be doing the Doki SMP next week.
I will have a Monday stream because I will be taking...
Because I'll do something on the 25th.
So I'll be taking the 25th off.
So there will be a Monday stream for next week.
No, it was December to February was super packed Because I
had the maid cafe stuff I don't know if you guys remember it
But the maid cafe stuff started in December Along with the
Doki Lan too So it was December to February Where I've been
all over the place
But yeah, I'll post the schedule Maybe tomorrow So we'll see
We'll see but yeah, thank you for joining me on the journey
for God of War Ragnarok I am very surprised it did not take
us that long to complete is there an after credit scene by
the way chat Is there an after credit scene?
I'm surprised I was able to complete this in under eight
hours not gonna lie I Was ready for at least a 10-hour
stream with how everyone was telling me they're like you are
not close at all and I was like oh my god all right I'm
ready I got food ordered I have food stocked up for later
with if we need it um
um I'm I that's why I ended stream early technically
yesterday because I went to bed early even though I didn't
have the best sleep I did try to sleep as much as I can for
today um I didn't do a lot of work yesterday I literally
like finished my stream um dinner and then went to bed
because I was like I gotta have because I was thinking I
wanted to do a Zatsudon after a chatting portion after
Mugenics but I was like no I gotta keep my energy for
tomorrow I don't know how long I'm gonna be streaming
tomorrow everyone tells me different hours they're like I
ate hours minimum and I was like oh my god if you convert
that to Doki hours That could be 10
Alright Alright We got our funeral Alright we're gonna call
it here But yeah Thank you everyone I hope you guys Yeah I
made dinner I bought a lot I made like Wait what the fuck
did I make Oh yeah I bought some I made udon Yes last night
Because I've been craving udon And I went to an Asian market
where I bought my ningo and so I also bought like Vietnamese
ham where it's like the cylinder thing and you just cut it I
fucking love Vietnamese ham I haven't had Vietnamese ham in
a long ass time so I like bought some and I just like made
it with udong and spam um god it was so good anyway guys I'm
gonna rest now um it was a it's been a great stream um
finally beat God of War Ragnarok it did not take us half a
year thankfully uh this time around.
It did not take us half a year.
I locked in for this time.
I learned my lesson from the last time we played God of War.
But now, now we locked in.
It did not take us half a year.
We're improving.
We're getting better at this.
Hey guys, thank you for joining me on God of War Ragnarok.
Thank you guys.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up
and move that blood flowing.
If you step for me, head to bed, because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.